.
I can't think of a crash retrieval case with live aliens better than Virginia.
Every single bit of testimony from separate people from all over the area,
all fits perfectly.
It's like putting together a piece of puzzle, right?
I think if this were a murder case, you'd have more than enough evidence.
Right here, the alien was alive in this bed right here.
Knowing that you sat in the hospital room with a live captured alien and
had direct telepathic communication.
You have the autopsy of this soldier who's died
because he basically grabbed an alien being.
Every time I say something's impossible,
therefore it can't be, therefore it isn't.
I've been proven wrong.
I'm here, round two, with James Fox, who I always say is my documentarian hero,
and now a friend, and I really appreciate you coming here.
Because we're talking about, I think, maybe the most interesting case where you
have a UFO, you have alien beings, and you have all of these witnesses in a town in
Brazil, in Virginia, Brazil, as late as 1996.
We're not talking about Roswell 70 plus years ago.
Or Magenta.
Or Magenta, you know, 90 years ago.
And you've just done an amazing job in this movie of documenting all of the, literally
the flight path of the UFO.
You know, three beings coming out of the UFO and them seeming sort of injured and afraid.
Maybe more.
And you show all of these witnesses coming from disparate places that have
zero reason to lie, have not made a penny off of any of their testimony.
And they're coming from this, you know, from Virginia, Brazil.
They're not, you know, selling books at like a conference in the Southwest in the U.S.
and like into the UFO lore.
Like they don't really have preexisting notions of what these things even are.
So hard to get those people on camera.
People have no idea.
They think like people are just lining up.
I want to be famous.
I want my, my, my notoriety to get on camera.
It's exactly the opposite.
People took years and in some cases, decades to come forward.
And, you know, this most recent revelation, which is in my humble opinion, the most compelling
firsthand eyewitness testimony in the history of the phenomenon.
I agree.
I fully agree with that.
Right?
And, and it's, and it's not just some random Joe.
It's the guy that ran all the hospitals, humanitas, regional, like Bono.
He mentions them in there, but in any case, he's a neurosurgeon and he had health complications.
He had a heart attack, then he got cancer and he was like staring at the ceiling of
the ICU.
And he was thinking, if I get through this, I'm I can't take this to the grave.
This is it's literally the, I agree with you.
It's the most amazing testimony I've ever heard from a person who was face to face with
an alien being.
For what?
Just three to four minutes, which is just remarkable.
And it's clearly, you know, he's a concert pianist, you show him at the end of the credits
playing piano.
Oh my God.
And, um, and he's a really well respected neurosurgeon and, um, it seems totally beyond
reproach and you see him, he's in the hospital and he's showing the bed that the alien was
on.
Crazy.
It's crazy.
And then he gets emotional.
You take him to a cafe nearby.
You get kicked out of the hospital.
He's like, I think I might've just lost my job.
So a lot of this might be, you know, a lot of detail for people to take in, especially
if they're not familiar with, you know, kind of the, the, the background of exactly what
happened kind of high level.
So we might be getting ahead of ourselves here.
So, so, so what happened in January of 1996 in Virginia?
Put me on that farm in January of 1996.
What happened?
So that was the, the object was shaped like a saw.
A rubber shape, like a school bus.
It was the size of a school bus and no noise at all.
We kept watching it because there was smoke, a light smoke wrapped around it.
But I even joked with her.
What is that?
Is it a submarine?
Because it was floating.
You know, he kept watching it until sit vanish this away.
It was shaped like a cigar.
You know, that along like that, like a cigar, roughly 20 miles as the crow flies from the
couple's sighting.
Farmer Fabio Furtado encountered a similar object.
From here.
I saw it.
It passed right by and made that movement over there in front, you see, and I saw it
all from right here.
Look, then it performed that exact same movement right here.
And then it landed way back there.
It was like a cigar just flying through the air.
It was January, 1996, probably the 13th.
And there are a number of witnesses to a cylindrical shape.
It was a cylindrical shaped object, rather large, the size of a little bigger than a
school bus.
Okay.
And it was like a metallic cigar shaped cigar shape.
Yeah.
There were no like wings or any visible means propulsion.
It didn't really make any noise.
And according to the witnesses it had, and for the first time ever in this recent cut
of moment of contact, new revelations of alien encounters, we actually have a map of all
the various sightings of it, which really helped put things in perspective for me.
Cause.
They did a great job of that.
Wow.
I was like, Oh my God, he saw it here.
This person saw it here.
This is the town of Virginia.
The crash was here.
It was like, it all makes sense, you know?
And uh, so they see this object and it had a tear in the back of it, which is very puzzling.
Like, Hmm, how did that happen?
Something came in contact with that object to tear it and have, they said it was like
a white vapor.
It wasn't like a smoke from a fire that you would have seen, it was like a white vapor
that was coming out the back.
It was clearly in distress.
And I was like, well, how do you know it was in distress?
They were like, it was struggling to stay in the air.
But they said, had the animals or the farmers, the two farmers had the animals not made a
ruckus at two o'clock or three o'clock in the morning, they would have not even heard
it or known it was there.
It was absolutely silent.
And they were expecting it to hit the ground, the two farmers.
Um, and, um, and then there was another gentleman, uh, Fabio Furtada at that farm.
And he said that, that it was make like it, like it was over his house.
And he was there with one other person at night.
And he said that it was making a sound like it was kind of in trouble and that it landed
on his farm.
It's the first time we got that testimony and that's like over here.
And then, you know, the object was seen here and here, and then it crashed right in the
middle.
Um, and then, uh, there was a gentleman by the name of Carlos de Souza and he was an
ultralight pilot and he was also a geography professor in Sao Paulo and he was going up
to go ultralight.
Yeah.
Ultralight flying with his friends early in the morning on January 13th.
And he sees, and he's a pilot himself, he sees this object, this cigar shaped object
with a gash in the back, just like everyone else described that was struggling to stay
in the air.
And he never once thought alien.
He was like, that must be some sort of weird experimental crap, maybe it was government
or air force, whatever.
It's it's in trouble.
It looks like it's going down.
So it was really early in the morning.
He turns off the freeway and he goes up to this place called the Maialini farm.
It was a dirt road.
And he goes up there and he sees it struggling to stay in the air and then it just goes boom
and hits the ground.
He's like, oh my God, I think just crashed.
They need help.
So he went up to the actual impact site, which was like a debris field, bigger than a football
field, maybe two football fields with debris everywhere.
Half of the craft was still intact.
And then the other half was just gone.
Like just debris bits everywhere, got out of the car and he's looking at it just again,
never.
How many months did he think alien?
Now it doesn't even enter his consciousness, right?
And he said, he's looking at it and he's like these little bits everywhere and he goes,
the smell like he pulled the, he was like, it's rotten eggs and ammonia.
He grabbed his shirt and kind of pulled his shirt over his mouth and said, my God, this
smell is so intense.
She immediately smelled ammonia.
It was like rotten eggs, a very strong odor, I had to cover my nose with the shirt I was
wearing.
Yeah.
It was like a liquid that you described, cause I was asking like an acid or some sort
of liquid everywhere that causing the grass and stuff to burn.
And he said it was maybe an acid or something.
Yeah.
Like some kind of liquid.
And because he was talking about the grass was kind of, was affected by it.
And actually if you, when we flew the drone over that exact alleged impact site, you can
see it's different.
The ground looks different in that zone than it does all around it.
I mean, it really does.
And he picked up one of the pieces and he said it was like aluminum, really light.
Like you couldn't feel it.
Very much like the Roswell people had described.
It's always what you hear.
Yeah.
And he said that he could crumple it up really light.
Like you could barely feel it in your hands and then when he released it, it regained
its shape.
It's the same thing as what Jesse Marcel said.
Yeah.
That's what he said.
It was weightless.
You couldn't feel it.
You had everything in your hands.
And then he goes, he goes, then all these military trucks started coming in from the military
base ESA from the opposite direction, which actually just a few months ago, we were there
and I took the drone way, way up in the sky and pointed it straight down.
And you could see where the ESA military base, the route that ESA would come in from.
And he came in from the freeway on the opposite side.
And that's when he was, he was threatened at gunpoint.
He didn't see anything.
Get out of here.
He was like, I was just trying to help.
Like, you know, what, what's the problem, you know, just trying to help.
I'm not, you know.
And that's when he said things got related.
Yeah.
It was really weird.
And then he got into his car and he left and he stopped at a gas station just a few miles
down the road to have a coffee and just trying to gather himself.
And that's when an unmarked vehicle showed up and they knew who he was, his name, his
wife, his address, his daughter, like all everything about him.
Two men approached me dressed in black suits, all perfectly aligned, very tall individuals.
They stood right next to me and asked me, are you Mr. Carlos de Souza married to so
and so your daughter, so and so.
They described my entire life story right there.
I turned to the man and asked, who, who are you?
What do you want to know?
How do you know all this?
It was perfectly clear to me.
Listen, you didn't see anything.
You just shut your mouth and you leave.
If anyone ever asks you anything at all, you didn't see anything.
You don't know a thing or else things will get no supposed to really weird for you.
All right.
So just get out of here.
I was at that moment completely startled.
I go, this is a little bit too much.
I'm thinking, oh my God, what I'm going to say here?
Like I'm petrified.
I'm like, this is too dangerous, because I'm going to die.
I'm going to die.
I'm just not sure why I'm in here, you know, right here, right now, I know it's
too dangerous.
I know it's too dangerous.
I'm just scared.
You're scared of the tomorrow, right, you're so scared of this.
I'm scared of the future.
You're so scared of your future.
Right.
That's the reason I put a blank on the end.
You're like, oh my God, so I put a blank on my head on this.
crashed craft and you drive a few miles away yeah and they somehow are able to apprehend you there
yep like the car that stopped had no plates did they have an accent or was it they were very tall
they had suits and uh they spoke portuguese and you know sometimes there'll be one person speaking
portuguese and there'll be a couple other people that'll just be silent in the background and that's
that happened in the case of uh louisa the mother of the two girls that came into direct contact
with the alleged alien um and she's like they were foreigners like how do you know well they
didn't say anything but they looked like foreigners and the money was foreign it was like american
dollars in a briefcase and um and he said that they were very intimidating they said you don't
you didn't see what you you know you didn't see that you know and if you ever talk about it things
are going to get very weird for you not they're going to hunt you down and kill you they're going
to get very weird for you which is kind of spooky you know what i mean do you think they were maybe
like the proverbial men in black well
you know it's so funny because i'd heard about these so-called men in black stuff dating back to
the yeah to the 90s when i was investigating you know it's like i investigated the phoenix lights
case and a lot of the witnesses hate when you say phoenix lights so they're like wasn't fair
much lights it was a massive craft you know yeah i could see the compartments it flew right over my
yeah the governor has now admitted israel and kurt russell saw yeah while he was flying his
a plane with his son he said he could land his airplane on her there you go yeah so we're going
into phoenix and uh we're going into phoenix and uh we're going into phoenix and uh we're going into
phoenix and uh we're going into phoenix and uh we're going into phoenix and uh we're going into
there's these bank of lights six lights in the shape of a triangle going back right over the
airport so i was investigating that case and i was working with a woman who was the councilwoman
frances emma barwood and um i was interviewing her and of course i was going after the governor
at the time i wasn't getting any traction with that and i was interviewing all the witnesses and
and uh there was one guy a vietnam vet and he contacted emma
Frances Barwood, one of the few elected officials, councilwoman, that was willing to, hey, all she
said was, let's investigate what happened, what these people saw. She was lambasted in the press.
Oh my gosh, you can go see they were making fun of her. This guy reached out to her, and I know
this because I was investigating at the time I was in touch with her, and he said, hey, I understand
you want to know more about this crap. I'm a Vietnam vet. I was on my roof that night trying
to get a video on a tripod of the hellbob comet, because the hellbob was over the sky, you know,
and I have a CB radio, and I was listening to the truckers come up Interstate 10 from Tucson,
and they were all describing this massive boomerang-shaped craft, and I realized,
shit, this thing's coming right my way. So he said, I was all set up with a tripod and a camera,
and I filmed it going right over the top of my house. Got great footage. Would you like to see
it? She's like, yeah, I'd love to see it. So they make
a video on a tripod of the hellbob comet, and I was listening to the truckers come up Interstate 10
arrangements where he was going to drop it off at her office. I don't know if it was later that
day or the very next morning or that night, two men roll up in an unmarked government vehicle
and suits, and he's like, he goes, they were very intimidating looking at me, and they were like
in these dark suits. It was really hot, and the only thing they really asked me was, you know,
they said they were from France. They're like, we're from Francis M. Barwood's office. We're
here to pick up the video, and he was like, oh, I was going to drop it off, but I guess I don't
have to. And he said, the only question they asked is,
uh, did they make, did he make any copies? And he said, no, I didn't. And so they took the,
they took the footage and left. And a couple days go by, he doesn't hear from Emma, so he calls her
up. He goes, hey, what did you think of the footage? She goes, what do you mean, what did I
think of the footage? I didn't get the footage. He goes, well, you had two men from your office
show up. She goes, I didn't see anybody around. So that was like the first time that I really
heard about these so-called men in black, and that was in the 90s.
Yeah, no, this is made fun of, you know, in a movie.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
But Richard...
Richard Dolan, you great UFO researchers, write about this phenomenon happening time
and time and time and time again. You have another example, which you cover in the phenomenon,
or I think in the program, actually.
Two witnesses were out hiking. They then saw a large diamond-shaped craft hovering.
It didn't move. It just hovered in the air without making any, any noise.
The witnesses looked at this for a while, and one of them had a camera.
So when the jet came along, they sort of stuck the camera out from behind the bush and snapped
six frames.
The two witnesses that took the photographs took like six prints, five prints, like color,
points of reference, broad daylight, two witnesses, military jet in the background. Like,
it doesn't get much better than that. And he was like, these men in black rolled up.
They were having their cigarette break.
They were fucking spooks. They were men in black.
And they stood outside in the pushing rain, speaking to them.
So in any case, when I got to the Varginha Caves with the men in black, I was like, oh my
God, these guys again. I'd heard, I could give you, I could go, go on for five hours.
Well, it doesn't matter. My point is I went all in on that.
Yeah.
And I did cover a little bit with the 1966 Westall UFO incident, the landing,
when I got ahold of Mr. Greenwood, the, the, the son of a...
The, the science professor. Well, that's a whole story about how I got him to go on camera. I
remember when I arrived in Australia, all the seasoned UFO researchers were like,
don't even bother. You know, this guy will never come forward. We've been trying for 50 years. I
said, just get me in the room with him. It was a great story behind how that whole thing goes. But
he talks about these guys, the intimidation, they showed up at his door, they're in suits,
like, you know what I mean? Some unmarked government agency threatening him, like putting
the blood, the fear of God in this guy. And.
Yeah. If you talk to Richard Dolan about who the men in black are, he seems to think.
OSI?
No. Well, this is really trippy. He thinks it's like counter-intel on behalf of the NHI or the
aliens or the ETs. Because if you, if you think about it, the level of rapid response, the ability
to show up and like, you know, kind of know everything about like, it's either like in 1996,
had way more of like, like, like think about 90, 1996, the, the consumer internet wasn't really
a thing. Like, you know, who knows how much information the government, like maybe the US
government had a lot of information on its citizens, but did they have information on a
citizen of Virginia on a, you know, this guy who was a pilot in Virginia and a geography teacher
in Sao Paulo? Probably not, you know? And then the ability to show up,
a couple hours after he had seen this crash craft.
So de Souza, did he see any beings with the crash? He just saw the crash.
Just saw the crash. And I asked him, I said, it was the, was the,
the section that was still intact. Was it big enough to have people? Oh yes. He said, no
question. Now, uh, did he see inside it? Not that I'm aware of. Okay. Yeah. I didn't ask him
that question. That's a good question. Yeah. I think if he had seen inside, he would have told me,
but he said there was a sec and he wasn't there for very long, but just a few minutes,
but.
The section was intact. That was still there. And it was about half,
half the size of what it was when it hit, when it impacted.
Seven days after Souza witnessed the crash, Hubert Ladera leaves this gym when he and several
friends see two military trucks driving into town. They follow them through the neighborhood
and come upon a military blockade.
We tried to force our way through and they raised their rifles, their weapons.
Did you get, did you all feel scared at that moment on that day?
The only time I felt fear was when the soul in, uh, when the soldier raised his rifle,
because until then I had never seen such a large weapon and no one had ever pointed
a gun in my direction, you know. And you have some reason to believe that
two or three beings came out and that, and one of the beings. And you have you,
you have the, you have the mayor on record testifying to this, the mayor's nephew.
Matthew's girlfriend was one of the three girls that saw one of the beings.
The news has just arrived at this very moment.
The girls have spotted some kind of creature up there, close to the Maraconon gymnasium.
Just around the corner from the military blockade, three young girls had an encounter of the third kind.
The sisters Valkyria, who is 14 years old, and Liliance, who is 16 years old, are also very frightened.
It's the first time they've come back to this very place since Saturday, January 20th.
That strange round thing, wow, it was incredibly strange.
And it had these things like horns right on its head.
Its skin was brown and it looked like it had some kind of oil all over its body.
It had a huge foot and its eyes were super wide and red.
And then I think you have some reason to believe that one of the beings made its way over the hill
and possibly to the Maraconon gymnasium.
And then it was captured with a net, is that right?
Yeah, that was with the fire department earlier.
That's why I keep thinking because that one was alive because we have testimony of someone that was in the area
when it was in a net.
They captured it with a net like they would with a wild animal or something like that.
It's so wild.
But it was screaming like a little baby.
That's what they say, screaming like a child.
Screaming like a child, yeah.
The fire department was dispatched to this location after receiving several calls
from concerned residents who reported...
...seeing something strange in the area.
First of all, I'd like to take a quick moment to acknowledge all the Brazilian UFO researchers
that have done a stellar job helping expose this story.
Claudio Covo, Pacaccini, Uberajada Rodriguez, Marco Petit, A.J. Givard.
I mean, these guys that came before us, Marco Leal has been on it for over 20 years,
my partner, he's amazing.
And the persistence of all of them and Marco and I knocking on doors,
like going downtown, putting up signs, like leading us to people.
Like, I just want to give one example of how we got to the girls.
Because the girls are like, this is not a career-enhancing move for these girls in a small town to be talking about.
They got made fun of, ridiculed, laughed at.
Like, their life was a living hell.
Men in black showed up at their mom's house.
And they got offered cash to retract their statements.
Yes, a lot of money.
And they did not.
They did not.
And the mother said, I will not have, my daughters are not liars.
That will not happen.
That's right.
They were very intimidating to her.
And like, so all this pressure and all this, you know.
But I was there with, I was in Virginia, I'm going to say it was my second or third time.
And it was probably 2012 would be my guess.
And I was doing a silly TV show, which I'm not proud of at all.
My bad.
But whatever.
It got me to where I am now, I guess.
And that was for National Geographic.
Oh, God, it was so bad.
Sorry, guys.
And we were out wandering in the jungle at night.
And I got bit by a spider.
Ooh.
And it was like midnight or something.
We had no business out.
It was so silly.
I got bit by a spider.
And by the fang marks, it looked like it could have been a Brazilian wandering spider, which is deadly.
They get me to this clinic.
And they had to go to an anti-venom.
And I was up all night getting this drip feed.
And then the next day.
I didn't get any sleep.
And the camera crew, the whole team, they were like, we're going here.
And we got this scheduled.
And I was like, I've been up all night, man.
Like, I'm on camera TV talent.
And you guys are expecting.
I was like, at the very least, I need to stop at a cafe and get a juice.
Because, like, Brazil is known for having incredible juice, right?
Fresh juice.
I love it.
Mango, papaya, whatever.
And they're like, no, no, no.
We don't have time.
And I was like, you know, the car was stopped.
The van that I was in was stopped at a stoplight.
And I just opened the door and got out.
I was like, you guys leave without me.
I'm not.
I need some juice.
I need something.
I need something to nourish me.
So I walked into this random, like, cafe juice bar.
And I'm in there ordering.
And this guy's looking at me.
And I think he said something in English.
Like, hey, are you American?
And I was like, yeah.
What are you doing here?
And I was like, oh, I'm kind of working with a TV show, you know, covering the 1996 Virginia incident.
He goes, oh, my gosh.
I dated one of the girls.
I said, really?
And.
What?
We're trying to reach them.
We're trying to find them.
And he goes, let me hang on.
Takes his phone out.
Boom.
Gets her on the phone.
Hey, what's it going to take?
And that's how we first met.
Whoa.
And so had I not been bitten by the, you know what I mean?
Like, whoa.
The way it all went down.
Yeah, I know.
That's crazy.
Really crazy, right?
The creature was there.
And we just came by this way.
I didn't realize that's closer than I expected.
It's like eight feet away.
And he was absolutely sweltering, sweating.
He was sweating profusely, and it was incredibly hot.
And so he was going through it, you know,
suffering from the intense heat, the scorching sun,
and the effect it had on his skin.
Remember, I said, hey, everyone, look over there.
Then he turned, I saw his eyes, and I immediately ran away.
So when he turned, we could only see his eyes
and what looked like a slit.
But we couldn't really tell if he had a normal mouth
like ours or something else entirely.
When they locked eyes with this being,
what were they thinking?
Well, it wasn't a human that we saw, honestly.
It wasn't an animal either.
And so these days, I truly believe
it's a being from another planet.
Back then, you know, we were always in pause.
We were children of Catholic parents, right?
In pause.
And that it could be a demon.
So that's why we ended up being afraid back then, you know?
So the three girls run to her house,
and they say, we saw this creature.
We might have been the devil, or whatever it was.
And do they get in the car and drive here?
Do they walk here?
How did they get here?
And what did they see when they got here?
She said, let's go there in the pickup truck.
And I told her, I'm not going.
I'm too scared.
I won't come back.
Then Louisa asked, please, won't you come with me?
So I finally got into the pickup truck, and we came back.
We ended up stopping right here.
Look.
In that very spot, I saw the creature's track, its foot.
I will never forget it.
I swear to God.
Oh, I'm still trembling.
Do you want to see one toe, then another long toe,
and then another toe like this look smaller?
Yes.
Roughly three hours after the girls witnessed the strange creature,
military police officers Eric Lopes and Marco Ceresi
drive down this road on the lookout for something unusual
when suddenly it runs right across their path.
These military personnel exited the vehicle.
These soldiers.
But most notably, Marco Ceresi wrestled with this creature to bring it under control.
It was captured by Marco Ceresi with his bare hands easily and taken to the hospital.
So what happens is Marco Ceresi, who's this soldier, apprehends this alien being, grabs him.
Yep.
Brings him into the vehicle, right?
And no hesitation.
Puts him on his lap.
It's so wild.
And then he ends up with this gnarly bacterial.
Infection and I don't want to get too into the details because Chris Ramsey is going to do an amazing follow up with you kind of which double clicks on this autopsy.
But you have the autopsy of this soldier who's died because he basically grabbed an alien being and it shows bacteria.
Yeah.
You're the guy, the founder of the company IPD and you could get the it's an acronym, but the founder of the company, Dr.
Giannini and the guy that did the autopsy.
Yeah.
On the deceased military officer, Dr.
Armando, um, participated on camera for this cut of the movie.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
You have the, the founder, you have the, the guy who provided the, the report and all the infrastructure for the report, the one who founded the company and the guy who founded the company and, and, and the, the autopsy guys both saying, and they are using words like goosebumps.
And then they're the ones speculating that the, that the claw from the ET must have punctured the skin.
And it's like this.
He said, the.
Bacteria most likely came from the, under the nail of the ET, which didn't mean to like, it wasn't like an evil ET that tried to kill this guy.
He just like accidentally in the process of grabbing it.
Yeah.
He got a little scratch right under his armpit.
Based on the circumstantial evidence that has come to my attention, it was a very distinct and deliberate scratch on the skin, clearly inflicted by ET.
I truly believe he was a victim of, of VTS nail.
You know, he.
Had a sharp claw.
Why was it so resistant?
What biochemical gain did it possess to completely escape the antibiotics as they were.
Scoping those antibiotics.
It.
Just sailed through destroying everything in just one week.
That's very, very atypical.
Yeah.
I won't go into detail about it, but basically never before.
Never since.
Yeah.
They've never seen anything like this bacteria.
This is, was an advanced bacteria that did things that nothing.
Nothing on earth.
bacteria on earth does and you see them in the movie saying that it's like incredibly yeah and
it's not anonymous they're not doing this anonymously neither is the neurosurgeon yeah
neither is the neurosurgeon and he's still working at the hospital today when we first started
selling merchandise at americanalchemymerch.com we had no idea how complicated and annoying
selling merch could be we talked to a dozen different platforms and companies comparing
shipping tools payment options website builders and it all felt like way more of a headache and
complicated than it should be we decided on shopify and within days our store was up everything was
running cleanly in an automated way so we could just focus on the brand and the vision we had for
it that's when it hit us ideas don't scale on inspiration alone they need a structure a
container shopify provides that structure it quietly powers millions of creators and brands
about 10
you
.
of all united states e-commerce from big names like jim shark and mattel to solo creators
building from their bedrooms shopify made it simple to build a store that actually feels
authentic to us which matters when your brand lives in a niche like alternative tech ufos or
fringe science and when you have a very clear brand vision plus their ai tools help write
descriptions organize products even clean up photos so we can focus on what matters and what
we care about building the best of our brand and the best of our brand and the best of our brand
custom merch line possible with the coolest designs
like our ufo cowboy tee and the atomic age tea
it can even hold together fun and
plus shopify handles all of the unglamorous more painful stuff shipping returns email marketing
also Zoe's plus oufos do its job well in a hybrid new results only managed to save yourself
in one clean dashboard
so you just have to take it slow it's like having a silent partner who
our favorite part of the product is the
dash pc
dashboard which gives us complete demographic information we can see where our
ordering ghostyy
orders come from making it easy to know who our most loyal consistent customers are around
social and uta
our CBD's website was1911.com
networking site was downhill short of right next cup short of half my heart every single day
around the world. That's just one example, but Shopify really makes your life easier.
Bring your next idea to life with Shopify quietly handling everything behind it.
Sign up for your $1 per month trial and start today at shopify.com slash jesse. Again,
that's shopify.com slash jesse, J-E-S-S-E for a $1 a month trial. It's just $1 a month to try
Shopify, the state-of-the-art solution in e-commerce. And they tried to suppress this
report and Marco Schirisi's sister, who you interviewed, basically had to sue them and
arrest the report out of them. And the wife couldn't get the autopsy report from her husband.
That's crazy. And she was like pregnant at the time. It's horrible. You know? Yeah.
God, that was one thing that Dr. Roger Lear, thank you, Dr. Roger Lear for tracking down
the wife in 2002. After a protracted legal battle,
the family fought.
He finally received the death certificate. It was produced by IPD Laboratory, the Institute
of Prevention and Diagnostics in Virginia.
Nesse exame aqui, nesse laudo, fala que ele tem uma presença de granulações tóxicas finas em 8%
neutrofilos, onde foi adquirida uma substância não identificada. Portanto,
que ele veio morrer de uma infecção generalizada, mas sem uma causa justa.
All the witnesses that claim that Marco Schirisi handled a creature, a strange creature,
it doesn't have to be from another world,
it was a strange creature. He gets some unknown infection. You did everything you could to save him,
and he died. Do you believe that there's some credibility to that story?
Sim, acredito que a história é de credibilidade. Ele expôs isso como um desabafo até para tentar
uma ajuda para si próprio, para poder salvar a vida dele, porque ele percebeu que ele estava indo e,
segundo a irmã,
He was not allowed to tell anyone about this.
Marco Eli Cherese, 23 years old, worked at B2.
The family only knows that he participated in a secret operation.
Do you confirm that your brother was in service on that day?
I confirm.
To find Marta, the sister of the deceased military officer, Marco Cherese,
she'd gone off, I mean, yeah, she'd spoken publicly at the time of the incident,
year two, three, whatever, and then just kind of people pulled back.
There was just nothing to gain and everything to lose,
like just going up against, you know, Goliath.
And people just want their lives back, you know.
And I went downtown and I was talking.
I would look in the downtown plaza, downtown Virginia,
and I would look for old people because I was like, all right, these pop, you know,
and I'd walk up and I was just asking.
And I remember my sound guy was from Rio.
And he was like, he looked at me and he was like, dude, are you insane?
Like, what are you doing?
I was like, you know,
I have a 0, 0, 0, 1% chance I'm going for it every time, right?
And so I was just going up.
And then I found this one old guy and he was like, oh, yeah, I think I know.
She moved to this location, that.
And we're driving around in a random goose chase.
We're going to knocking on doors in random places.
Three or four hours later, we knock on this one door.
Door opens.
There's Marco Cherese's sister, Marta.
It was like, and I remember my sound guy looks over at me and goes,
you're the luckiest son of a bitch I think I've ever met.
I said, no, well, not necessarily.
I was knocking on doors to find her.
And her husband was very protective and he was wearing this white wife beater
and he was just ripped.
And he was like standing in the background like you give me the nod
and I'm going to rip this guy's head off like to me.
Right.
And and she doesn't know who the hell I am.
Everyone's paranoid.
Like, I'm some American.
And I said, I'm here to give your your your brother justice,
to give your brother a voice.
And that broke the table.
Broke the tension immediately.
Yes.
And it was like, OK, let's talk.
And then we and then that's how I got in with Marta Tavares.
When her brother falls ill, she asks about his involvement with the case.
And this is the story, the creature from outer space.
Look, this story will be a big deal.
So what?
So one of the beings gets captured with a net.
Yeah.
The other being.
So the only.
Yeah.
The only two really solid ones that we have.
But we have information on others up to five.
But again, I only reported on two because that was the most concrete eyewitness testimony
that we could get our hands on.
And that was one capture in the morning by the fire department with a net.
Apparently that one died.
But that's one that was crying.
And then the other one, which was more critical.
And then the other one, which was Marco Cherise and Eric Lopes.
And it's interesting, actually, because when you watch the movie and a lot of people miss
this, when we doorstepped Eric Lopes and a lot of people, a lot of people criticize us
for that.
Like, how could you just doorstep this guy?
You just show up at his house.
It's like, well, we exhausted every other possible avenue for decades.
Yeah.
All the researchers had like he wasn't talking, period.
And he was the military transport guy.
He was the one driving the car.
Driving the car.
When his fellow intelligence officer, police officer Marco Cherise jumped out and killed
him.
Marco Cherise jumped out and grabbed it.
Because the being was in the way of the car.
It went right across the road, right in front of him.
Yeah.
And it was just a couple of blocks away from where the girls had seen this creature just
two hours earlier.
And Eric Lopes.
Everything lines up.
Basically said, I will deter you with bullets or something.
Like he threatened you.
He said he'd shoot you.
But before he said that, he's like, if you're here to talk about the E.T., he won't talk.
He referred to himself in the third person.
It's kind of like, it's kind of like the police showing up at your door at a party and,
you know, and you answer the door, you see the police and you go, there's no drugs in
this house.
It's like the police.
I was like, I didn't ask you about any drugs, but now that you mentioned it, it's interesting.
You know, he said, if you're here to talk about the E.T., something like if you're here
to talk about the E.T., he won't talk.
Yeah.
We didn't even say anything yet.
We just said hello.
Well, that plus threatening to shoot you.
Oh, of course.
You know, not a normal reaction.
He said that.
He's like, he brought the E.T. up.
We didn't bring the E.T. up.
He did.
Yeah.
So it's like read between the lines there.
Tacit admission of something.
Yeah.
And when I was standing there trying to make sense of what was going on, because it was
like, everything was happening really quickly and they were talking, you know, and like,
I speak French and I speak a little Spanish and I could really like, when I'm in the field,
I really want to understand what's being said.
Even when I was in China, I was like learning Chinese.
I just, I have to be able to communicate.
So I, I can, I have this level of focus where I really try, but this things were happening
really quickly.
He was making threats, I guess, about shooting me and shooting everybody else.
Even there was a 10 year old kid there and I'm looking in the eyes of this guy and he's
up, he's like up in a window on the second floor, looking down at us and he's got something
in one hand.
And I don't know what, if he had a gun or whatever he had, but he's military intelligence.
He's P2.
Like he probably doesn't have any problem.
You know?
I don't know what happened to the teeth, but I'm looking in his eyes and, and, and
I hear all this commotion going around me, but I had a moment where time almost stopped
and I looked into this guy's eyes and I just saw eyes of someone that I've never, I never
seen before because like, they look so grief stricken.
They look so sad.
Like I was just like, I, it's like time stopped and I'm looking in this guy's eyes and I've
never seen eyes like that before.
Like if you could imagine harboring.
Or witnessing a murder or something really intense and then having to be quiet about
it because maybe your family's threatened or your life's threatened or who knows what,
like you had to harbor that for the better part of 30 years, like the toll that would
take on you.
Well, you, you see it even, even you hear it with, with what he says to you in the movie
and you, and you sense that he's been threatened.
His family has been threatened in that.
He probably feels like kind of half a man or something like he's been, you know, he's
been submitted, uh, through force.
Yeah.
So Eric, Eric won't talk.
No.
What, what just happened?
I'm trying.
What happened?
Is that Eric Lopez?
Who is that?
Yeah.
Eric Lopez.
That's Eric Lopez.
Yeah.
He doesn't want to talk at all.
Terminate.
Okay.
Oh my God.
That was Eric Lopez.
Just saw him.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll go talk.
Did you get him?
Dave, did you get him?
Please tell me you got him.
That was Eric Lopez.
Did you get him in the window?
Yeah.
If that guy had nothing to hide, he would've just said so.
That guy was driving the car.
Yeah.
That Marco Trezzi was in.
We received an unexpected request for a meeting from the chief neurosurgeon
at Hospital Regional.
the same hospital where military police officers marco sherrys and eric lopes allegedly had taken
the live alien they'd captured on the road dr italo venturelli the head neurosurgeon at hospital
regional was on duty in the icu when he had the most extraordinary encounter of his life in this
room or which room this room right here
his eyes they were like a teardrops red much redder especially right here you know and he
was well partially covered he was right here you know but he was he was still alive
he looked at the in the eyes of the creature yes in this bed in this and what what did the
creature say to you what i saw the red eyes his face was white his eyes were red and he wasn't
showing any suffering at all now if there was perhaps a possible telepathic communication
yes yes right there you see as if to say you know something like i'm perfectly fine i've been well
looked after he said yes for sure a communication as someone would say yes i am okay i've
received care that's what he felt from the the expression of the being to speak without speaking
according to dr italo a being underwent a procedure by his colleague fellow neurosurgeon
dr marcos venicio neves who died in 2018 of a heart attack the other primary witness was his
partner a fellow neurosurgeon who was slightly below him
marcos venicis and marcos venicis uh there's a lot to that story as well
he had a heart attack in 2018 he didn't survive and he passed and he did surgery
he getting a little lo 간 he did a procedure on the being yes yes yeah i know it's so and and so
he died in 2018 18 yes and ventorelli um he said he was face to face with this being and
what did he what did he describe the story like in 2038 yes it's a great story you know if you're a
scientist you know al virtually like bits of it so he described that he was a presidential candidate
and you know when i came Atlarea with and he was hearing the president this lightsail hospital
and he's like what is all these talking about you've been told he's been Schwezzeff it's all the German
coaches who are being he's been doing he's being the last 16 day audience that they know all the
as far as that interaction.
He said that, this is incredible,
it's hard to kind of wrap my mind around it, you know.
It's like I've had very,
I've only had a couple of cases
where I'm almost kind of pinching myself during filming.
One of them was with the former governor of Arizona,
Fife Symington, when he confessed after 10 years
that he had not only believed about the Phoenix Lights case,
but that he too was a witness to the event.
And then he looked into it,
and he, as a pilot in the Air Force,
he said that thing could not have been from here.
And I said, how did you know that, governor?
And he goes, because of its size
and its flight characteristics,
it couldn't have been from here.
It had to be otherworldly, is how he put it.
And that was a moment in my career where I honestly,
and I'm not just making this up,
I remember sitting in my chair,
and I'm going, did the governor of Arizona
just say that he too saw it,
and that he looked into it,
and he felt it was otherworldly?
And I'm like, I think I must be dreaming.
And so I'm like, pinching my,
I literally grabbed my leg and I pinched it.
And I was like, no, I feel that, I'm not dreaming.
Then I said, I bet the cameras aren't rolling.
So I looked over at the camera to see if the, you know.
And then when we were with Dr. Italo,
the neurosurgeon in regional hospital,
that he just snuck us in the back gate,
like, you know, with all cameras rolling,
and the audio guys and everything.
And then he starts talking about,
like, this is the bed, this is the ICU.
I was like, holy shit, this guy's just going full Komodo.
Like, he's just saying, the hell with it,
whatever the consequences, this is what happened.
I was here, I sat with it in this bed,
right here in this room for three to four minutes.
After several minutes of interaction with the being,
Dr. Italo told us the military burst in and took the being,
then threatened the hospital staff to remain silent.
Ask him how it feels to be sharing this information
after 29 years.
And how do you feel about sharing this information?
I'm crying.
It feels like crying.
Excuse me.
He's my nephew.
He's different from us.
There's nothing wrong with him.
He's my nephew.
So this is, you have a neurosurgeon who's, you know, again,
extremely credentialed.
Everything to lose, nothing to gain.
He's had some health scares, and giving you this testimony,
and he freaks out, he's going to lose his job.
He ends up giving you the testimony in the cafe.
His good friend had done surgery on the being?
A procedure.
Marcos Vinicius.
Did he say anything about that surgery?
what is surgery like on an alien being so apparently it was uh and and i'm not qualified
to do you know i'm not a neurosurgeon but from what i understand is that there was swelling from
head trauma and that he had released the pressure by putting i guess they do a little hole or
something like that where it releases the pressure it was something like that it was a procedure
to release the uh-huh from the head trauma see that i would imagine it was maybe something to
do with the accident i don't know but no but no but that that is interesting that sort of
satisfies like if i were to throw any sort of skepticism at this it would be um you know how
are you dealing with alien organs like what do you you don't really know what to do yeah you know
but if it's just a like a head pressure you know release or something that that makes some sense
to me could have been head how did he protect himself from the bacteria if he's doing was he
was he just who's in the icu everyone in the icu has full protective gear on yeah
yep because we even just to walk in with no patient we had to put all the gear on you can't
go into the icu without it yep you got face mask glove everything apron and it was probably with
marcos teresi um there was probably some interaction with his blood because he there
was a maybe a a punctured wound or something and so i wish like hell marcos venesis hadn't died
for so many reasons i mean interviewing a guy who's done surgery on an alien being i know it's
really frustrating however yeah we have not given up like i said by the time your audience watches
this i've already been back and we have a huge meeting with all the doctors as many as we can get
so have you talked to his family at all oh yeah oh yeah marcos venesis oh marcos venesis's daughter
marcos venesis's he had a mistress and he had a he had a kid with the mistress we we we talked
with the the wife and um did they all say that no they were very very very very very very very very
guarded okay but not like no it didn't happen like okay well you know like guard what you come
in as outsiders to a place it takes a while like like it took when the film came out and that was
actually one of the reasons why the the police officer he's like you're doing a serious
investigation one of the reasons why i'm talking to you is you you're investigating something that
i participated in like you you clearly are taking this seriously i'm i'm providing a platform we are
for people to come forward and not be ridiculed not be laughed at taken seriously and like you
know kind of like first time in decades right so they're seeing this is a real effort to really
get the truth out and it's power in numbers you know and um um and again i i think this is the
beginning of the beginning on this case i i believe that i mean this is an extremely compelling
like new account new cut of the of the case but i think it's going to get better
yeah well i think if you believe that that's going to determine the outcome because you're
the prime mover of a lot of this stuff and i i know you've given credit as it's due to many
uh of these local brazilian ufo researchers uh but i think as far as mass exposure you are you
are helping them you know really get this thing out you keep going back and so i really admire
that if this were a court case you would have an overwhelming amount of evidence that something
happened whatever the thing is that you're trying to do you're trying to do something that's not
you're trying to prove in court this would be far beyond the threshold of evidence that you would
need i think we could sway any jury i think you could sway any jury and so the venturelli thing's
just fascinating you end up in a cafe with him yeah he gets very emotional he starts crying
because clearly he's held this in for 29 years 29 years and could you imagine the weight of that
on your shoulders no i can't you're watching all this speculation you're watching all this
conjecture all this media coverage the debunking of the case and you're watching all this
speaking going on from the military like excuse me the witnesses you know adamantly saying you
know this is what i saw particularly those the three girls you know and then knowing that you sat
in the hospital room in the icu with a live captured alien and had direct telepathic
communication face to face face to face man's eye to eye doesn't get any more incredible than that
like as someone who's been around the world yeah interviewed people like you know you have close
accounts of the third kind you know you have close accounts of the third kind you know you have close
accounts of the third kind you know you have close accounts of the third kind you know you have gilt
iticks an lad???? but you also you know what it looks like for the pseudo wars like as flash 오
you you know what's in there for the third one you know you look at the emulation what exactly
is going on what on earth possibly is happening with the third one you looking at that right now
you know where are those um are they bringing the thorus the american sameness back to you know where
people claim you know entities connected to a craft that's in the wild i mean it happened in ruah that
happened in socorro um you know lots of cases in china you know all around the world but that's like people
seeing a landed craft and seeing entities connected allegedly to the craft and that's close account test kind
eyes of this creature and despite the fact that it was in captivity it had control of the whole room
usually the person experiencing the thing is kind of discreditable often they live in you know
somewhere in the woods or something the interaction occurs in some remote place and it's just this
kind of inherently ephemeral thing where you have to take their word for it i would actually say
those people are sort of more trustworthy in some ways than like you know uh often people who are
kind of insidery types or whatever but in this case you have a person whose credentials are
unimpeachable he runs a chain of hospitals he you know people are are their lives are on the line
works on people's brain works on people's brains he's a neurosurgeon he's a concert pianist
and you know clearly all of the incentives go in the direction of him not revealing any of this
stuff and because he's had a couple of light life-threatening illnesses and scares
he comes out and speaks to you what does he say about his interaction with the being
the being was very calm and it was it was uh it had sort of acquiesced to being in captivity and
was very calm and that it was it was okay that it wasn't suffering it wasn't in pain
um and he said when he looked into the eyes of it it read his mind like it could just read all
of his mind and he said it was very calm and it was very calm and it was very calm and it was very
he's like it was an advanced intelligence and i kept saying like what do you mean by that he goes
there's nothing here on earth like it he called it like an angel and it was it was um compassionate
caring like it an advanced intelligence and i said explain that he goes way more advanced
than anything on earth way more advanced than than myself just way beyond and that you and he
said that one of the last things he said was there's so much
from the eyes of that being
just looking into the eyes and it's just amazing
to think you know think about that and you know you hear other cases in the wild where people talk
about you're looking in the eyes of the creature ruiz zimbabwe you know sukor new mexico i remember
the wife of london zamora looking at me and she goes i don't know what happened when he
looked at me i don't know what happened when he looked at me i don't know what happened when
at that creature but he was never the same like the community there's some communication that
occurs with the eyes and that's exactly what he said he said there's so much to learn from them
and they're advanced like more advanced somehow than than human consciousness which is and then
what do you say about the physical characteristics um big big head almond shaped eyes they were red
now interestingly the skin was more white than brown and i don't know this is just speculation
but when the girls came in contact with this being that was most likely the same being that
he had in the hospital because the chain like the girls saw it they got within 10 feet of it
it was really hot it was a really hot day in the summertime january summer over in brazil
and it was suffering it was like kind of exuding some kind of weird smell like almost like a skunk
would you know when it's fearful or feeling threatened or vulnerable but his eyes were red
his skin was oily i couldn't see him with an open mouth laughing no not happy but sad hunched over
pale and sad and he had no hair and i saw that he was frightened just as i was frightened the
creature was also frightened the destiny the fear that we ourselves possessed just as we became
afraid of this this being whose nature we do not know and it was suffering and the girls
said it was suffering in fact when when all three girls came into contact with that creature
of them the two sisters grabbed each other by the hand and hightailed it out of there and they
realized they had left katya behind akachi was the oldest she was probably 21. and um and valkyria and
liliani the two sisters stopped and realized shoot we got to go back and get katya and katya
was locked eyes with this creature and uh it was pleading to her because i asked katya what
was it saying it was like i need help and it was suffering i need help it wanted help and
thought my gosh you imagine how different would have been if they'd gone with if the girls had
taken the creature and and hidden or you know who knows like given it aid or whatever anyway
the girl uh liliani katya stayed behind the youngest she was like maybe 14. liliani was 16.
katya was 21. uh liliani ran back and grabbed katya and yanked her out of there and then
the reason why we're pretty sure that that's the same being that uh dr italo
had a direct telepathic communication with in captivity is because we did all aerial photography
of the area and if you look at where the girls came encounter it like late afternoon with the
creature just a few blocks away is where the capture occurred it had to be the same being
it was just literally two blocks away from where the um two military officers marco cherise and
eric lopes captured the creature around six o'clock something like that about two hours later
two two and a half and then they took it to one little um clinic and apparently the doctor came
out and took one look in the back seat and there was you know marco cherise military officer with
this creature on his and he's like i don't know what that thing is but get it out of here so then
they went to regional hospital and that's where italo was so it makes perfectly good sense we knew
that that creature went to regional and so it went it when the women saw it it was like brown or dark
and then when he saw it it was somehow it was wider it was it was more of a white big red eyes
just like the girls described the little ridges on the on the forehead just like that spindly arms
same height same exact body structure everything exactly the same but the skin was more white and
do you think it was because it had was emitting the ammonia or sulfur because both everybody says
that it was it smelled like rotten eggs yeah and it was ammonia or sulfur or some some sort of smell
immediately smelled ammonia it was like rotten eggs a very strong odor i had to cover my nose
with the shirt i was wearing i couldn't stand the smell that was right here inside my nose
it lasted for about 20 days and i have no idea where that awful odor came from i even went so
far as to wash my nose with alcohol and water just to get rid of that smell stayed in the
sign in the sinuses for days if not weeks right and like um there was another one which was one
which was one of the deceased ones we interviewed a radiologist and i think he was at regional
hospital pretty sure it was regional and uh he said that the room where he did the performance
of doing the x-rays that stank like for they had to close that wing of the hospital down for days
and they disinfected the whole thing and he said it took days and it was in his sinuses
it was everywhere did the smell leave but even after being washed and disinfected the epidemic
still lingered in the world in fact our sector was closed because it couldn't accommodate external
patients due to the very strong odor so we're having a big meeting in a week uh-huh we're
meeting with uh pretty much all the doctors wow yeah some of them you know at humanitas hospital
uh have stories some of them aren't ready to come forward just yet some of them might want
to come forward but there's power in numbers strength in numbers
and um according to the book by roger lear uh there was another creature that was alive that
went under a procedure because a lot of them got hurt in the crash evidently um that also
had communication with the two doctors but they're at humanitas and so we're trying to find those
guys right now and roger lear was contacting me it's probably 2013. and he was like i know you're
doing something on on virginia and i got to talk to you i got to talk to you i said yeah we
definitely got to talk let me come i got to go on camera there's things that he just i don't know he's
body discusses we could discuss and uh and i said i kept like postponing postponing i was so busy i
was working like 17 hour days i was so busy i could barely talk and um he goes well you got really
angry with me and he's like well if you're not going to meet with me i said how are you dr leer
roger i it's not that i don't want to meet with you i just i i don't have the bandwidth right now
and he goes well take my tapes gives me his tapes and i don't know how much time went by but i don't
know i i can't say uh but i taste save myself
na na clean you know all those poor Dan like those two are going to kill you though and i can't bring
them back but you know i was yeah very happy i spicy um and i love sticking with the people of達
I transferred the tapes.
I sent them back to him and he died.
And then fast forward, and that was very unfortunate,
fast forward probably 10 years, I'm guessing, or ish,
I was making Moment of Contact
because I was going to include Virginia in the phenomenon
and then I just couldn't squeeze it in.
There's too many moving parts.
Anyway, so when I was making the whole movie on it,
I was like, oh, shit.
I was like, the Roger Lear tapes.
So I got the tapes.
He wrote a book, got the book.
And the book was a transcription from the tapes
because I had the tapes and I read the book.
But there was one section that wasn't in the tapes
that was in the book, and that was,
he met with two doctors from Humanitas Hospital
and they talk about a creature
that was also undergoing some sort of procedure at Humanitas
and then all of a sudden there's this crazy thing
that occurs in the room where there's this communication
and weird smoke and just crazy.
And the communication was basically like
the entity saying to the doctors
that we feel sorry for you, the human race,
because you don't realize your potential
of who you really are.
Really?
Yes.
Which is the same message that the Renro Zimbabwe.
It's the same message these school children get
where it's like you don't understand
how special you are and your potential.
True potential and stuff like this.
So I was like, oh my gosh, if I could just get the name.
And apparently,
Uber de Jaro Rodriguez,
who was one of the leading investigators,
a lawyer who's gone,
I don't know what happened to him.
Pacaccini got threatened.
He disappeared for 20 years.
Uber de Jaro Rodriguez,
God knows what he has
because he hasn't come forward and said yet.
Pacaccini apparently was shot at.
Really?
Yeah.
He talks about it recently
because he disappeared for 20 years.
Where's Pacaccini?
He said he was shot at.
He was shot at and he had a gun and he shot back.
And he says he would put his right hand on the Bible.
Yes, he said he would testify.
Like, like he would,
he would put his right hand on the Bible
and he would take a public lie detector test.
About there being video and footage of this alien.
That he saw.
I'm Vittorio Pacaccini.
I am one of the leading investigators
of the Virginia incident since the very beginning.
I know and I saw with my own eyes
an alien creature kept in captivity.
And this 35 second video,
it was right there.
One of the alien creatures
with two millions,
one of the millions of soldiers
holding the creature by the shoulders.
The creature was really ill,
was not feeling good at all.
They tried to give the creature some fruit and water.
It didn't accept.
And the reason why they filmed this creature
without superior authorization,
it's because they were pretty mad
that the American militaries were coming to Brazil
to take all these material, not, you know,
not only the pictures, the footage,
but the creatures itself and the spacecraft
as they took it to the United States.
So some other militaries friend of mine
had the chance without authorization
to make this movie.
And right now I'm willing to put my right hand tomorrow
on a Bible and take a live public lie detector test
that everything I'm telling you is true.
The truth.
Yeah.
Now he grew up in Tres Corazones,
which is like the region, Minas Gerais,
where the ESA military base is.
So he knew all those people that worked at the base.
They knew him, he grew up there.
So like after all the investigations,
his life's threatened and all the stuff that went down,
he said he disappeared.
I think he went to go live with his mother
or something somewhere for 20 years.
And then when Moment of Contact,
the first version came out in 2022,
that's when Peccacini came back on the radar
and it was like, hey, you know what?
I'm ready to get back in the ring.
Yeah.
And finish this fight.
And so, yeah.
So you have multiple people in the hospital system.
You've now gotten military whistleblowers.
You have civilian witnesses.
I have the guy that drove it.
You have the guy that drove the being.
Yeah, that saw it and drove it.
To say like the amount of disparate uncorrelated sources,
I think is just-
Unbelievable.
And that comes from you literally touching down in Virginia
and on a piece of paper,
like do you know what happened in 1996?
What does he think about the case?
Does he think it happened or it didn't happen?
Absolutely.
What are your feelings on Virginia?
You have two types of people in this movie,
people who are extremely afraid and admitting what they saw.
And all of those stories line up.
Everything lines up perfectly.
It all lines up perfectly.
You have a flight path of the UFO.
You have all these witnesses and these disparate, you know,
places who aren't coordinating clearly.
And then, so that's one type of person.
And then you have the other type of people
that are like lying through their teeth.
And so, like the commander at-
Yes, Lima, General Lima.
General Lima.
Yeah, we're in touch with him now, by the way.
Oh, amazing.
You got to talk to him because even if he lies to you,
you know, it's like, you see the smugness when he goes,
you know, we were serving our country that day.
Yeah, national security.
Can we get some, yeah, can we get some details on like,
how you served the country that day, what you did?
He said, no, absolutely not.
And, but he says it in such a, like a condescending, cynical,
like, I don't care what you think sort of way,
and then walks away.
There was another part to this,
when interviews were conducted,
and that's when Euclides and Calado,
the two young men from here, traveled all the way
to the sergeant's school of arms in Tres Corazones.
Then they managed to ask a question.
Then the sergeant went inside, came back and said,
no, but aren't you going to say anything about the case?
Look, if you ask one more question, you'll be arrested.
We were investigating the case at the ESA headquarters.
The sergeant-
The sergeant's school of arms, and I had never been arrested
for doing my job, neither before nor after this case.
I was just having a normal, regular day at the barracks,
you know?
Then around 9 o'clock in the morning,
we received orders, a mission, to get some vehicles ready,
you know, some trucks, specifically
for an important operation.
And that we, our unit, would be deploying,
we would be moving out, heading directly
to the barracks.
We were given the order that we should proceed
to follow a number of specific vehicles,
which were clearly unmarked, and definitely not military.
So I followed this military man, you know,
who was from the Secret Service,
passing through the city center near the hospital,
if I'm not mistaken, the regional hospital.
And afterwards, we went to Humanitas Hospital.
When the instruction was given to us,
to back a vehicle up into Humanitas Hospital.
When I was approaching the entrance,
how exactly can I express it?
Of the hospital's immediate surroundings,
I noticed a container, a stainless steel table
with a container on it, you know, with several doctors
and other staff members holding clipboards.
As I was analyzing, it seemed that everyone else was also caught up
in the same thing.
And when I realized, I saw something completely different.
You know, a different kind of creature with skin
that was very oily, very, I'd describe it as having a sort
of silicone-like texture, and that sight really startled me.
But what truly caught my attention,
what later convinced me that it wasn't a human being
at all, was its foot.
Everyone was completely taken aback by the news.
They were all incredibly, incredibly surprised.
We have, for the first time ever as well,
we have the police officer, which had been trying
to get to him for so long.
Marco Leal was going by his house, knocking on his door.
He would set up arrangements for us to meet with him.
And it was always, it was like slipping between your feet.
It's like trying to grab a bar of soap in the bathtub.
You know, it's like, pooh, pooh, like you got your hand on it,
but then it's like gone, you know?
And that was the former chief of police, Aguilar, Pedro Aguilar.
And he had, allegedly, according to people
that we tracked him down, he had a photograph
of one of the things.
But anyway, he described the activity at the base.
He was at the base as chief of police.
He was invited in there, and he said that,
he described it just like everybody else.
Every single bit of testimony from separate people
from all over the area, all fits perfectly.
It's like putting together a piece of puzzle, right?
Not once have we had it any other way.
Yeah.
You know, we're putting these pieces together.
So now the piece we're missing is on the American side,
and we want to get with Humanitas Hospital.
So it's like ongoing.
Yeah.
Well, the chief of police says this is not a story,
it's history.
Yes.
And, you know, he-
You remember well.
Oh yeah, it's a great movie.
And it's, he just, he said, you know, this happened.
I participated.
He said, I participated, absolutely.
And are you at all conspiratorial about the fact
that he just died and that you were,
about to go in a couple of weeks to go see him?
Yeah, again, I know.
And allegedly he has a photo of the ET beam.
Yeah.
Do you think that that timing is coincidental?
I mean, anything's possible.
It's very unfortunate.
Was he in good health?
Do you know?
I mean, he's, you see him on camera.
Yeah, and that was, you filmed that, what?
You filmed that like not too long ago, right?
We knocked, so it was really crazy, actually.
It was just a couple of months ago.
And we were gonna doorstep him on the way to Varginho.
And I say doorstep.
He didn't just show up at the door, right?
Yeah.
And for some reason I was like,
I wanna stop and get a slice of pizza.
And everyone's like, we gotta keep moving.
It was like five o'clock or 4.30 or something.
I really was really hungry
and I wanted to get a slice of pizza.
So we stopped.
Reluctantly, half the crew was like,
oh, we gotta keep moving, blah, blah, blah.
Well, as it turns out, it was perfect
because we, the owner of the pizza joint,
you know, gave us pizza, gave us like really good,
you know, we took like an hour
and we just spent a really fun time having pizza
with the owner of this pizza joint
and near the area where we're going.
But it set us back at least 60 minutes, possibly 90 minutes.
But you know, it was a little later.
Maybe it was like 7, 7.30 at that point.
And we show up at his house
and they had just gotten home like 10 minutes earlier.
So we would have missed him
had we not gone and stopped to get that pizza.
And what we did was is we, you know,
we started talking to him at the door.
Then we went inside and we had some, we had audio.
One of us had audio rolling and the guy in the car outside
had, you know, our sound guy had, you know,
it was remote transmitted back to a receiver.
That was just, you know, the audio.
And then we're talking, getting to know his wife, his son.
And then I said, would you mind if we bring a camera in here
just to kind of, you know, document the moment a little bit,
just ease our way into it?
No, that's okay.
So in comes the camera, we're all sitting down talking
and his wife, I'll never forget this.
And I think I have a cut of it somewhere,
but his wife had these like,
her eyes were so big and like, kind of just like,
and her wife was looking at her husband,
like just wouldn't blink.
And I'm looking over at my cameraman, Dave,
and I'm like, are you getting, you know,
she's just looking at him.
Like, I'm thinking, does she have the photograph?
Like, does she, you know, I don't know.
Is she worried that we're in there probing?
And at one point we asked him like,
when things got more comfortable and he goes,
I'm a, I participate, I'm a witness.
He saw the creature under a tarp,
maybe the bottom half or something.
And then he went into, as a military base,
he did the activity, helicopters coming and landing.
He goes, more brass than I'd ever seen ever before.
Like there were higher ups from all different corners
of Brazil all there.
Maybe even blind at some point.
No, he did say the Americans came, they came to Campinas.
He said that too, yeah, and took the goodies.
But he seemed to be in relatively good health.
I mean, you know, it didn't look like he was gonna win
like a triathlon or anything, but he was in,
I mean, he's in the movie.
Yep.
And he just died.
Yeah, and he might've had a photo or footage.
Well, we talked to two witnesses.
One of the primary reasons that led us to him
were two people that described,
he pulled the photograph out and showed it,
and it had one alive, one deceased creature,
and it had military police and fire department
in the picture with their faces that, you know,
that's,
that's the range of the witnesses that we talked to.
And when I pressed him on it and I don't wanna push too hard,
but I definitely pressed him on it.
I've got the footage.
He said, I was like, well, when I talked to you
a couple of years ago on a video Zoom call,
you confessed that you had the photograph
or that at one point you had the photograph.
And now you're saying you don't have the photograph.
Like what's, you know, and I really pressed him on it.
What did he say?
He said, well, there's certain things
within the police department that have to go on set
or something like that.
Oh, come on, dude, just let it out.
You know, and I feel the frustration from people out there
like, oh, there's not a picture, there's not a video.
First of all, I never give up and I'm not giving up.
I will never give up.
I'm getting closer.
We are as a team are getting closer and closer and closer.
And the developments that are happening are unprecedented.
It's an ongoing investigation.
I'm not giving up.
I think this is the case
that's gonna blow it all out in the open.
That's my humble opinion,
because I can't think of a better crash retrieval case
involving the Americans.
It's recent enough where most of the people
are still alive, right?
Like, unless you can,
I can't think of a crash retrieval case
with live aliens better than Virginia.
No, I think it's the best recent case.
And again, I think if this were a murder case,
you'd have more than enough evidence that it happened.
Yes. No question.
And so like, there's this, you know,
you want a smoking gun, maybe you don't have that.
Not yet. But like, I bet you,
in the world of deep fakes,
if you've produced a photo,
the goalposts would move.
And there'd still be skeptics who'd say,
oh, look at the photo, it's blah, blah, blah.
It's blurry, blah, blah, blah, you know.
Unless the neurosurgeon who shot the video came forward
so you have providence.
That would...
I think that'd be pretty good.
I think it'd be hard to do that.
That would be about as good as you can get.
I think that'd be as good as you can get.
Right? And then it is what it is.
It is what it is.
Yeah.
Jose Fernandez is this air traffic controller.
Yes.
Who, what does he say?
His unit was responsible
for monitoring specific airspace over the state of Sao Paulo.
Do you know anything about this case?
What I am aware of is that the US Air Force
made a landing in Campinas.
A specific aircraft belonging
to the United States Air Force landed there in Campinas.
And following that, two helicopters took off
from the very same Campinas airport,
proceeding to an entirely unknown destination,
which we later came to understand
was the city of Virginia.
They landed, collected something
that no one knows what it was,
then returned to Campinas,
placed it inside the USF aircraft,
and then they took off, they were gone.
And the mission was, what we were told, was silence.
So it was really funny, actually,
because let's back up a little bit by a couple of years.
And I was just talking to Lou Elizondo about this.
Lou was pestering me before I had a final cut
of the first version of Moment of Contact.
And he was like, I need a copy.
And little did I know about what was happening
behind the scenes.
I need a copy.
I said, Lou, it's not done.
He goes, I don't care, I need a copy.
And I said, okay, sure.
He goes, have you had any idea who's watching this right now?
And basically, Lou was like, okay,
this case is absolutely amazing,
but the air traffic controller who talked about USAF coming in,
they didn't have any government regulations.
They didn't have government approval.
Usaf is US Air Force.
Exactly, but I kept hearing Usaf,
and I was like, Usaf, what's this guy talking?
Oh, United States Air Force, the acronym USAF.
And that was one of the aspects that Lou really wanted to share.
To this day, he hasn't told me exactly who's watching it,
but I think he was like, maybe if there are certain
restrictions on people like Lou or Grush, who knows,
like they could show him the movie, show him, it's a compelling case.
But at the same time, he's been doing this testimony
and then having the flight control,
what do you call the radar control officer,
the people that monitor the planes
that are coming into Brazil?
What do you call that?
Air traffic controller.
Air traffic controller, okay.
So, it would be an air traffic controller talked about this,
you have to have government approval to land a foreign plane
coming into Brazilian soil, and apparently,
this plane deviated from going to Sao Paulo to Campinas.
And Campinas is where we know, according to all records,
the eyewitnesses including the guy that drove it that's where the et went so for the have the
united states usaf landing campinas makes perfectly good sense like i said earlier all the pieces of
the puzzle line up it all lines up perfectly like every single person there's not been one
conflicting testimony there's been a date here and there where it's like oh well maybe it was earlier
maybe it's later we don't know but everything else lines up perfectly and you use the united
states freedom of information act yes to try to get information from the air force yes about
flight law you saw that yeah and so and and from the us to virginia in 1996 and and what came back
well i tried to i tried to cover all of our bases and uh our team we filed a foia and uh in 2022
i think it was yeah it's probably 2022. and i've forgotten about it quite honestly because it's
like years went by and all of a sudden we get a response from the cia which is weird
i don't know i mean i'm not a huge foia guy but i mean the cia yeah like really
and it's basically like you know because i asked for records i was thinking like okay so let's just
like back up let's give it like a window of 10 days or whatever so we know the incident happened
a lot of the sightings were on the 20th of january so why will you back it up a little bit
crash a little earlier so i think it was like january 13th to say january 27th something like
this just to cover you know any planes that came in from the united states air force what was a
10-day window two-week window that landed in campinas get all those flight records because
i was talking to
an individual who for a long time was anonymous and then he was so knowledgeable i was like
wow this guy is incredible who are you and he goes well actually my colonel in the united
states air force i was a fighter pilot blah blah and he has since come forward with us
and he had a really dramatic ufo encounter in 1980 or something like that but he was
giving me guidance on like what to ask and where to ask and all that stuff
and um blanket statement from the cia basically that's like either national security
classified or exempt from foia because of xyz because of this 1949 yeah provision secrecy
provision i can't even get a flight record it's always a tell too when you uh request from one
agency and then they forward it to the other agency which the other agency would obviously have
you know this this article came out in the daily mail about the office of global access
run under the cia around their rapid response you know global crash retrieval team and um
the the article is amazing like it mentions i think doug wolf as like the head of the oga
and so they probably would have been in charge of this sort of thing so the fact that the air
force is forwarding this to the cia is such a tell cia runs all foreign intelligence obviously
for the us such a tell that they were involved in this case i mean it's it's it's honestly funny
it's like an admission of of of you know involvement in some ways uh you know i just
interviewed a guy named dan sherman and he wrote a book called above black
and uh he was a cool title amazing title insane story he was a air force electronics intelligence
all of his stuff with you know his elant electronics intelligence career lines up with
like i've i've had multiple elant people come out after this interview i've done with him
saying this guy was definitely u.s air force elant like like just very matter of fact very
intelligent kind of on the kind of traditional vector of of signals intelligence
and um he said that he was part of this secret nsa program and it was called project preserve
destiny and it was he was supposed to do this kind of continuing elant education you know in air force
but while he was there he was taken to this complex this nsa complex at maryland
this was in 1991 or two and he was told to drink this you know drink and uh and then kind of hook
himself up like match the tones that he would hear with the air force electronics intelligence program
these headphones that this computer would would play and and lock into them and that's how he would
kind of gain telepathic access to alien communication and here this was really
interesting independently this researcher foia the air force said does you know just asking for
information about project preserve destiny his name is noah roddick i've been noah if you're out
there please confirm this because i don't believe he mentioned dan sherman's name at all they forward
the the foyer request
to the nsa that's telling right there yeah and the nsa of course gets back and says you know
we can't we did not confirm or deny the existence or non-existence of this program didn't they say
that in my foyer it's the same thing right yeah yeah yeah but it's such the bigger tell is you
have one agency forwarding it to the other agency it's like okay that then the second agency was
obviously involved why wouldn't the agency you sent the initial thing to just respond absolutely
yeah i got
i get i get emails all the time people reaching out on all the various platforms
i got an email from someone and i could pretty much like i could read it pretty quickly and
determine you know what i mean like some experience i've heard i've had been contacted by
alleged witnesses and stuff like that yeah for decades
and you could kind of sift out the crazy pretty quickly and um i think it was a year ago maybe
maybe a little over a year ago i got this email and i read it and i just i time stopped i was like
oh oh my gosh and it was basically someone that claimed uh i have the email i'll show it to you
offline um claimed to have been part of the virginia operation from campinas it was a usaf
he goes i was on the flight no way yes i swear to god what happened did you get in touch well
so i was like oh my it was just this moment like i was i was overwhelmed with excitement right
and i gave all the details i'll let you read it and um i was involved this has weighed on me for
almost 30 years of my family and yeah you have to be very careful how you reach out to me if you do
it this way or that way i'm going to cut all ties like it has to be this way you know blah blah blah
and i was like i'll whatever you want let's do it whatever makes you comfortable then i didn't hear
anything for about 24 hours maybe a little longer and this individual this individual said oh my
systems were hacked and that wasn't me that wrote that no way so did you do some follow-up and
oh hell yeah figure out who this person so yes and and but but when when this individual reached
out and i have a proton email now which i'll provide to you you can put it on the screen at
some point yeah well yeah because there was it was through google it was through gmail when i
thought well that was silly like why did you contact me through gmail yeah you know that's
easily hacked and it really wearied me yeah when i got it yeah but i only way oh that was only he
didn't know that i was hacked and it really wearied me when i got it yeah but i only way
leave me a number i couldn't find him on signal like so i responded just the way he told me to
respond and the feeling i had certainly from his response later was that somebody he got a phone
call something happened shut this down i don't know but it seemed so authentic like it seemed so
like this guy was really part of it i don't know if that guy is listening to this message right now
in any way shape or form like reach out you'll provide the proton email that yeah you can put
it on i'll put it up yeah thanks yeah but so
uh did you do some background research on this person i figure out i i did through some
connections of mine yes it was the air force uh uh marines he was marines marines yeah okay
and um did so is it plausible that what he was saying was correct very interesting yeah
i mean he gave like you'll see do you find any colleagues of his or anything uh no and and uh
you know since then i i was putting out the program and then in record time i put out the
new cut of moment of contact nine months from concept to completion to delivery nine months
which is a history like i i have had so little bandwidth for anything else there's so many things
to follow up on i'm going back and forth to brazil we gotta find this guy have you heard
of jonathan waygant yes i interviewed him in the 90s with uh yeah what am i talking about you have
an interview with jonathan waygant which steven grier edited yeah in a weird way yeah i was
actually there for that interview and i i went around the country with steven grier and he was like
just because i was like oh this guy says he's got all this access to people and i wasn't even
prepared for landing cases let alone crash cases back then i mean i heard about roswell but but i
met him and he was in his 20s and i was in my 20s and i was like boy this guy and he was so paranoid
at the time yeah this is the 90s well he was beat up he was paranoid and he was talking about like
it was one of the interviews that i was on steven grier's anyway he left an indelible impression on
me because i thought he was going to be a good guy and i was like i'm going to be a good guy and
i saw behind the scenes how terrified he was he was debating on whether i didn't even come forward
at the last possible minute he talked about i think either he was in the helicopter or they
mentioned the fact they could take him up in the helicopter it was a very big forest they could just
throw him out anywhere he would never be seen or heard from again like well he got right up to the
craft he went to the craft he said there was like a green liquid dripping out of it he said there
was an arm with i think three or four fingers it like a like a biological piece of an entity yeah
and i haven't i haven't watched the whole interview i haven't watched the whole interview
since i operated the camera for that interview with with dr greer and um but he left an indelible
impression on me like i was like well he because he was a marine right yeah that's why
i mentioned maybe the connection with this guy reaching out to you maybe there's some you know
and the thing is is like i wasn't really prepared at the time to process like crash retrievals
anything beyond roswell i know it's been a kind of a slow evolution for my personal like sure
my personal journey you know because i'd heard about i heard about that was my first case where i
was like boy this guy is credible man i mean i i i felt like he was crazy super incredible this
happened in the early 90s he was a part of operation laser strike in peru yeah and this
egg-shaped craft crashed into dripping dripping dripping from and he had telepathic communication
with it it was it was buried for about a 45 degree angle and into the side of the uh into this end of
the side of the the cliff there the the ridge it was dripping this serp like uh like serve viscosity
this liquid uh it was everywhere all down everywhere when we went down there because
there were plants and everything it was it was weird it was a a purplish green color and it
kind of like like fluctuated like you couldn't really when you you'd look at it one time then
you look at it again and it would like it's almost like it i don't know if it was like a
lava it was just changing but every time you looked at it you saw a different shade of greenish purple
and the being the being was uh uh basically sending them very similar signals that
that sent you know uh ventarelli the the neuroscientist and the the the daughters
or the the the sorry the women yeah um it was saying uh help me help me and he started to walk
towards the craft and they showed up and then they they apprehended him they beat him up people
in virginia are terrified that don't have evidence just they're just they're the fact that they
witnessed the event or drove the creature or whatever aspect you know they they
they experienced they're terrified now obviously the ultimate you know holy grail of evidence
that i'm bending over backwards to get my hands on and we keep getting close uh
is film footage yeah now i know through experience that if i do get my hands on it and bloody well
we've gotten close uh i got something to worry about and i've thought about that many times like
uh could i upload it to a server could i send it to 10 different people yeah how do i deal with that
that scenario in fact i had a really recent i had a really vivid dream just recently um really vivid
like in fact when i was watching your show with joe rogan yeah he had he had that dream yeah that
really vivid i had a really vivid dream where i was in i was in virginia and i was in a very crowded
area i think it was like a conference or we're having a screening or something and um lots of
activity lots of things and i was like oh my god i'm gonna be like oh my god i'm gonna be like oh my
god i'm gonna be like oh my god i'm gonna be like oh my god i'm gonna be like oh my god some gentleman
walked up to me and he handed me a thumb drive and he just slipped in my pocket and he just
looked at me and he kept walking i was like i've got this this has to be the footage
right but in my dream i was going what do i do like and then i just felt this dude maybe that
happened i just got the chill now i have a target on my back like what do i do like
i feel like i'd have a target on my back to get the hell out of there i need to get it
uploaded as quickly as possible you know go to a fancy hotel in sao paulo i don't know but anyway
and if there's one thing that i've learned in this field don't draw quick conclusions don't
have that knee-jerk reaction like suspend your judgment listen to the testimony because it's so
easy to go that's impossible that couldn't possibly have happened without the whole world
knowing about it well that's that's people have an allergic reaction to everything that doesn't fit
their kind of mental model how the world works but it should always it should always be follow
the evidence absolutely
it should it should always be like okay what actually happened and then there's beyond that
there's speculation as to what those things are i often think even ufo researchers jump to the
conclusion that it's a thing came from another planet when you know we don't know what these
things are that's why they use non-human intelligence which on the one hand sometimes
seems sanitized pc and part of some controlled disclosure like uap was supposed to ufo like uap
is supposed to ufo and i like ufo better than uap you know i think it's kind of better in old school
it's hard to say that it's proveable but like also i i kind of like the nhi thing because it's
we don't know we don't know we don't know and you really just have to follow the evidence
specifically and you have great theorists people like mike masters you talk about that
them being beings from the future and maybe they are being uh who knows i'll be the first one to
admit i have absolutely no idea where they come from what they want why they're here
yeah i can speculate i can look at like i don't think the government is sure of yeah either but
Okay. Over the decades, I've gone, you know, you look at what they do and that's pretty compelling, but then you look at what they don't do because all they'd have to do to, to reveal their presence openly would be to hover over the next Super Bowl. Right. I mean, but they don't do that. They've done some pretty bold moves over the years. Like in the fifties, uh, 57, I think in Italy, some big game they were.
Oh yeah. Yeah. You know, they've done some pretty cool stuff. I mean, Phoenix, Arizona was pretty phenomenal. I was when everyone's under the night sky to get a glimpse of the hell Bob comment and that massive boomerang shaped craft and other crafts as well. Pretty bold, pretty bold stuff, you know, but then you look at Travis Walton and it's like, well, they clearly, if you're, if you're going to take, if you're going to take the account of seven witnesses, you know, at face value, they cared enough about him.
He probably got in the way of the propulsion where they grabbed him.
Fixed him and then deposited him in the area, in an area on the outskirts of town that was close enough to like, he could get help, but not too close to reveal their, their presence.
They cared about him, but had they dropped him off where they picked him up, right. He wouldn't have made it. It's a very remote area of the snowflake Arizona up in the mountains where that encounter occurred. So I thought about, like, I think about those things. I think about, you know, Socorro, like officer Lonnie Zamora, like face contact, you know, locked eyes with one of these beings.
They got back in the craft and left, like they didn't want to have contact. They didn't want to have communication much more than anything, whatever happened when he looked into the eyes of these creatures. So they're in on the secrecy as well.
Yes, clearly. Yeah. Right. I mean, you can draw that conclusion pretty definitively. I would say that many of these experiencers. Yes, exactly. If you take the, their accounts at face value that, but there, there is some level of contact. I mean, look at Rua. I mean, look at 1966 Westall, you know, thank you, Shane Ryan and James Rigney.
Um, that case is compelling because, you know, once again, it was a school, 10 30 in the morning, broad daylight, broad daylight, 300 plus witnesses standing out there watching this disc zip around in the sky with a little airplane falling around it. And then the thing lands. And then the kids run over and a handful of the kids see it sitting on the ground within 10 feet. That's a pretty bold move. I would say. Yes. Yeah. As far as sightings go. Yeah. Yeah. In plain sight. Yeah. Anyway, it's, it's, it's a complex.
It's so complex. And I feel, I feel almost like I know less today than I did 30 plus years ago. Although I know the phenomenon's real. I know there's a coverup. I know that the government, I say, no, I feel very comfortable. The government has got very definitive evidence about this, you know, bodies and craft and all that stuff. I just, I don't know what they know. In fact, I just asked somebody who probably I'll remain nameless, but I was talking to somebody that I feel would be in a position to talk to.
And I said, I was like, how many people have the bigger picture? And this individual was like, and I believe me, I trust this individual. And, um, um, 10, 10 have the bigger picture. That doesn't mean they have the full scope.
Yeah.
But yeah. And I said, well, so like how many people know what you know? He goes about 30. I was like, so 30 people know what you know. I was like, well, um, is it, I've heard that.
Some people say it's a little scary. Is it scary? And, uh, the individual's like, yeah, I guess it could be a little scary. Yeah. Mm-hmm. Yeah. It's a little scary. I know I'm dying to know. Right. You know, maybe with the information they have isn't correct. Who knows?
And, um, I looked over and Leslie Keen was watching me have this conversation, you know, this is recently. And I see her looking at me across the room and she's like looking at me. She knows.
She goes, I know that.
I look on your face, James, when I see you locked, like you're, you really want to know something. She goes, I didn't want to interfere. And I'm like, just about. So I was like, well, what, well, um, it's like, well, what, what, uh, what's the intent? You know? And then somebody like butts in and, hey, you know, I've always wanted to meet you. And I'm sitting there like, oh, like, I don't know if I would have gotten it or not. But according to this individual that, that it's not like they didn't, I didn't have to fear for it.
I didn't have to fear for my safety kind of thing. And this could be all wrong. I don't know. But, but that the intent was a little scary, a little scary.
Yeah. Yeah.
Well, what do I know? I don't, I don't know.
It's hard to say.
Jesse, I don't know.
I don't, I don't either, you know, and that's, that felt like the framing of the age of disclosure, like there, you know, that there was some sort of, um, you know, they were prepping the battle space and they care about our nuclear assets because it's just like we would do ISR on a foreign adversary or whatever.
You want to know what they're working with.
I don't believe that.
I don't, I don't.
Um, and that's not to say, you know, if you're, you're a hammer, everything's supposed to look like a nail.
And so if your job is American national security, like, you know, maybe that's the way you're supposed to orient yourself towards this.
But like, I don't, I don't believe that.
And I don't, I don't think that should be people's a priori biases going in, especially if that's their first touch point towards, you know, the phenomenon.
That's, that's not my personal belief.
And yeah, I mean,
look, you just spoke to, you know, Tala Venturelli and, you know, this thing was like an angel and it was higher consciousness than ours.
And it wanted us to know how special we are.
And even that could be a form of deception.
You know, it's always like, you know, you guys are doing harm via like, you know, these environmental catastrophes that could be some sort of deception where they're trying to clamp down and control us.
Who knows?
But I think, I think knowing that they're bad somehow.
I mean, this, this.
This thing's been, whatever's been going on, it's been going on for a long time.
I think well before Roswell, well, well, well before magenta in the thirties.
Look at, uh, wonders in the sky by Jacques Vallee.
That's a great example.
Yes.
Incredible.
Yeah.
Or passport to Magonia passport to Magonia.
Exactly.
So, so this has been going on for a long, long time.
So I, I just, the idea that there's going to be some sort of rapid juncture or break in their orientation towards us, where they start to view us as some sort of big threat, uh, you know, clear, I, I do.
Think they do care about our nuclear stuff and are trying to enforce some sort of homeostasis of the earth, protect it.
Perhaps it could affect their reality.
Yeah.
It could affect them somehow, but I, but I, I mean, you'll hear things like, oh, they activated the nuclear sequence.
Well, guess what?
They turned it off after they activated, you know, they always turn it off.
In most cases, they deactivate it in most cases.
They deactivate.
Yeah.
So, yeah, I don't know if I buy that, but, um, you know, I'm open, but I, you know, the one line that I.
Remember, and I, I actually think I, I think I got this with Tim Coleman.
I was doing out of the blue.
I should watch out of the blue again.
It's been a while, but, uh, Robert Salas, former launch control officer.
I just love this line.
And I'm sure a lot of you have heard it, but I was like, well, wow, that's amazing.
These, you know, these craft we're seeing over the base and these nuclear installation during the peak of the cold war, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And he's like, yeah, he's very calm.
And I could see exactly why he was a launch control officer.
Cause he was very.
Measured and every word was carefully crafted and he was just calm.
You know, the kind of guy that you want in your corner when all hell's breaking loose.
Right.
Cause he's going to be very methodical measured and like not panic and do the wrong.
And he was like, yeah, you know, James, uh, message was, uh, pretty clear in my book.
Um, so almost like taking matches out of the hands of a baby, you know, I thought, wow, that's pretty cool.
Whoa.
Yeah, it is cool.
And, and, and solid reassuring a little bit.
It is.
And you know what?
He he's.
He's not alone.
Most of those guys who are in Bob Hastings, amazing book, UFOs and nukes say that that's what they, you know, they're like, we don't know, but we think that the message is, you know, you guys are playing with fire and not, you know, we're trying to deactivate your tip of the sphere defenses against us.
Not that we're trying to dominate.
We're talking between September of 66 and March of 67.
We lost.
30 missiles to UFO activity.
It's wild.
Yeah.
30.
That's pretty, pretty insane.
And, and I do think what that guy said to you, as far as I think, I think there is a tip of the spear as far as government knowledge on this stuff.
But I think if, if, you know, maybe the biggest misconception of all is that they understand all of it.
Yeah.
You know, I think they're learning from you just as much as you're learning from them.
I really do that.
It was really funny.
Yeah.
Go for it.
Well, I was at this event and, uh, and, and I was with Leslie and there were all these men in suits and she's like, Hey, there's a, these guys are from the agency.
And, you know, I pretty much knew that, you know, they were very nice.
And I, I didn't assume anything.
I, I was like, oh yeah, you know, and I've been investigating this case, you know, in Virginia and they're like, oh yeah, no, we know exactly what you've been doing.
Yeah.
Not in a threatening way, but like we follow, oh yeah, we're following this really closely.
Like.
For sure.
Like, you know, isn't that funny?
Yeah.
No, I get, I get that all the time.
Of course you do.
Yeah.
And I've had people on the inside ask about you.
Oh, there you go.
Like, what do you think about, what do you think about this guy, Jesse Michaels?
I was like, he's fucking amazing.
That guy's putting the pieces of the puzzle together that I just like, whoa, I'm taking notes on the sideline.
That's why I mentioned you on Joe Rogan.
Cause I was like, this guy earned it.
That was the nicest plug I think I will ever get.
You earned that brother.
That means so much to me.
You earned it.
It came from here.
Well, I know it did.
I know it did.
And I, I got emotional just watching it because it was, that was like 10 minutes or something.
I'd be like, you're a rock star by the end of it.
Cause Joe didn't know me then.
And he was just like, okay, I guess you've loved this Jesse guy.
Thanks, Jane.
Cause I've been watching you work and I'm like, this guy's operating on another level.
Like you're just incredible.
The way you're putting the piece of the puzzle together and like doing deep dives and all these different aspects.
I was like, whoa, like this is incredible.
Well, we're.
I'm standing on the shoulders of giants and, and, and there's no way, you know, like you were making movies while you were painting fences.
Yes.
Danny ditches, Brendan rebar, pouring cement, painting houses, parking cars.
Yeah.
So like, I think it's really easy to post de-stigmatization of the whole topic, New York times article in 2017, all this stuff, you know, it's easy to make these YouTube videos.
So, uh, you know, I, I, I, I think, you know.
All of us who are doing that.
Oh, you a huge debt.
Oh, people like Jeremy Corbell and Ross Colthard, a huge debt.
And so, yeah, no, it's, uh, thank you for saying that, but, uh, and there, there are people like me too, like UAP, so many people ask me to do that.
And, and I don't, I, and I, so many people, oh, I heard you're going, I always try to keep it secretive.
I heard you're going on.
Like, can you please, you know, no, no, no.
It's like, you earned it.
It was like, when you called me and you said, thanks so much.
I was like, dude, don't thank me, man.
You earned that one.
Like, yeah, that's.
I meant, I meant.
I meant it.
Yeah.
I re I really meant the, the world to me and, and, and Joe's become a good friend.
That's incredible.
When I saw him on your show, I was like, my God, that's so cool.
That was the most surreal moment.
So cool.
It was so epic.
Cause he, he's also talking about.
He respects you too.
Like he's got tremendous respect for you.
No, I don't know.
It's incredible.
Yeah.
I just, it's, it's so nice.
Maybe you should, both of you guys should aim higher, but.
It's, it's always nice to like feel appreciated.
Everybody wants to feel appreciated.
And you know, one of the things I'd love to say right here and right now is like,
you
know, I really like to see more kindness between fellow re everyone really, especially
with the people you disagree with.
Yeah.
You know, and less, less impugning people's motives and thinking
that they're bad faith actors.
Absolutely.
Because, and there are all these people who I went into this world thinking, oh,
but they're part of the insider crew or whatever.
And then I'd meet them and I'd realize that like, yeah, maybe they know a
few like kind of spooky-ish people or whatever, but they're really just
trying to figure it out and they're trying to get the information.
You know, a good example of that is actually Tom DeLonge.
Yeah.
Where like, you know, I, I, uh, you know, recently.
Remember when he went on Rogan?
Yeah.
And Rogan was, it was too much.
It was too much too soon.
Well, well.
Cause he was probably right.
Right.
He was right about a lot of stuff, I think, but he, he, it was, um, too much
where he wasn't in a position to, he could like say a high level thing.
And then Rogan obviously wants to get low level.
He wants to know all the details.
Yeah.
And then he would say like, I, I can't really fully, you know, tell you,
like, I'll tell you after the show sort of thing, you know, I was like,
oh, I can't wait for the show to end.
Right.
But, um, you know, I find him to be extremely earnest and cool and smart
and have like some sort of working worldview around this thing that, uh,
you know, seems to be pretty coherent.
And, and I think a lot of his, you know, uh, engagement with people on the inside
were his own, just really vigilante desire to like get a lot of this stuff out.
Yeah.
In, in any way he could.
And he has some interesting stories that I hope he tells at some point.
I want to shift gears for a second, because you have just, uh, a compendium
of incredible historical interviews and interactions with some of the people who
are the most important people in UFO history.
Uh, I want to talk about Philip J Corso.
Yes.
You have maybe the last interview with him alive.
Yeah.
Uh, he obviously wrote the day after Roswell, um, he was, uh, head of the,
the Pentagon.
It's a foreign technology desk.
He was a witness to the creatures.
Maybe he says he was, he says he was, but in the day after Roswell, that was also
co-written by William J Burns and that might've been, but no, but I interviewed
him and he told me about when he was taken in at Fort, it was okay.
So they started the journey in Roswell by truck, I believe it was.
And some of the debris went to right Pat on an airplane, but I think
the bodies, according to Corso.
Yeah.
There was a stop along the way.
In any case, he said that he'd heard that there were some bodies and they went
in and they opened up with the caskets and he saw the body from the Roswell.
No way.
Yeah.
In early July, 1947, Corsa was post duty officer in Fort Riley, Kansas.
There he claims to have seen a body transported from an airbase in New Mexico.
Oh, I'm back.
And there was five crates there, like five or six.
I think it was five.
I listed one up and here's this body there in floating in fluid.
First.
I thought it was a child.
Because it was small.
Then I looked at this head and all right away, and this was only happened a matter of seconds.
And then I put the end back down and the head was different.
The arms were spindly, the body, it was gray.
So right at that moment, I figured, I don't know what this thing is.
So like an intelligence business, I just better put it in the back of my head here and wait to maybe in the future.
I get cooperation so I can evaluate what it is.
Yeah.
He said that in your interview.
Yes.
It was really funny actually, because when I went to the 50th anniversary of the Roswell case that took place in 1997, uh, in Roswell, New Mexico, and it was a scene because we had like members of Congress, there was Congressman Schiff, I think it was, who was saying like, I don't know what's going on here, but I've been getting, you know, I've been getting the, I've been getting like stiff arm by the airport, you know, and I'm making the inquiries and why would you fly a, you know, uh, a weapon.
Yeah.
And he noted that all of the Roswell stuff was deleted.
Oh yeah, yeah.
All the archival material on the sea.
They sent him to an agency knowing that agency didn't have anything.
And this was all happening.
More people were coming forward and then boom, this guy, you know, Phillip Corso who apparently, according to him, and he told me this directly from him, his mouth to my ears, he said that they rushed the book to print with William Burns because they wanted to make the, they wanted to ride the hotels at the 50th anniversary of Roswell.
of roswell and all the attention it was getting and that there were a lot of discrepancies in
the book that he was upset about that you know this is what he told me and and i uh when he
came to roswell there was a flurry of activity in one of the hangars and he was surrounded by
all these news reporters oh my lord you should have seen it was a feeding frenzy like
and i'm looking at him and i'm like i gotta get i gotta get an on-camera statement but i was a
little kid with a camera and i was like you know what i'm just gonna elbow my way in there i don't
care and i fought my way in there and i got my camera and i asked them a couple questions in
the movie i'll give it to you you can show it and um and then the next day i found out where
he was staying what hotel he was in and i i just thought you know what i went to the reception i
said oh i've got a meeting with philip corso can you i just forgot what room he's in would
you mind you know and i went to the room and um oh we were expecting you like you know and uh
oh really like i was like so we sit down and we do an hour and a half long interview whatever it
was i don't hour hour and a half got a lot of stuff out of them again i'm happy to provide
whatever you want and um and then michael hessemann arrives german guy and he was late and
he was all sweaty and flustered and apparently he had scheduled the interview that i got with corso
but he showed up late i showed up i was in the right place at the right time i got this sit down
with corso when michael hessman should have had it and as it turns out he was all flustered and he
was late and he had no sound gear so i gave him my sound gear because when i got about i would say
it's about an hour and a half and he talked about why he's coming forward because it was grandkids
and he's like i'm old i'm gonna die soon but you know i want the world to know if this thing
happened i was a witness i saw and i remember thinking because there was a lot of controversy
after he died and he was no longer in a position to kind of correct the the record i guess but i
believed him
i believed him i looked him in the eyes and i really did believe him and i think i still
believe him to this day and i think he got a really bad rap and maybe it was too much too
soon i don't know but he told me i'm coming forward for my grandchildren and he goes i saw
the bodies like he looked like a little kid big head big eye you know all the typical spindly
arms spindly legs how many fingers didn't i don't remember that part because you know it's
interesting you say in in virginia there were three three three digits yeah and and it was uh
the the paper it's drawn you know the three fingers or whatever you recreate it and you know
i've seen beings in peru that are skeletons with three fingers and the three toes and three three
fingers and they carbon date to between 800 and 1700 years ago and one of them has a tridactyl
fetus inside of it so there's inheritance between tridactyl mean tridactyl means three fingers
so so one of them has a a right okay a fetus with three fingers and three toes in it
wow they all have dna associated with them and further testing is being done right now
so i'm like okay both of these things are happening in south america
is that just a skeleton of what yeah and they have elongated heads but they didn't undergo any head
binding they don't have any of the stress fractures involved in head binding wow super
weird virginia brazil those things had three fingers and three toes so the question is like
and and and didn't dave grush say that some of the craft recovered were
archaeological digs or something like this he said bob lazar said but david grush said that the that
the skeletons that i saw in peru looked like things that he's seen in classified settings
wow and so so that could be the same thing that happened in virginia that that being and we could
have literal mummies of those beings for all we know Bigelow i remember i met with Bigelow he had a
I met with Bigelow. I got contacted by him in 2009. And I don't think I was ready for what
he told me at the time. And I'm quite honestly, I don't know if I'm still not ready. What did he
say? Well, it was funny actually, because he talked about the complexities of disclosure.
He reached out to me through his secretary. I still have the email. And they said,
Mr. Bigelow wants to congratulate you on a job well done for, I know what I saw.
And that's cool. I looked up Bigelow and I kind of knew who, you know, I was like, oh,
wow. Would Mr. Bigelow like to get together? Yes, he would actually. And so we arranged a
time where I would go to his house and this is like 2009 probably. And we had lunch together
at his house in Las Vegas. And he starts telling me about the complexities of disclosure. Do you
understand kid? Like, you know, the implications and they're so vast impacts on organized religion
and this and that. And I honestly, I hadn't really thought of the complexities of disclosure.
And I was like, yeah, cool. You know, and he's talking about that. And then he goes,
he goes, yeah, and they're walking among us. And I said, what? And he goes, what do you mean?
He goes, I mean, exactly that they're, they're walking among us. No, no. I think I took that
and I put it in the back of my head. Cause I was like, you know what? That's just crazy. Like you
gotta be kidding me. You know, at the time I, I don't know. I took it with a grain of salt.
Uh, maybe they are. I don't know.
I mean, it would be pretty funny if they were, because, you know, here we are looking out
across the cosmos for any sign of intelligent life, you know, with all the various NASA programs,
you know, looking, uh, for water or whatever, oxygen or atmosphere, you know, all these various
planets. And it would be funny if they were like right here, you know, and maybe they are, you know,
maybe they are.
Yeah. Well, they, the, Hal Puthoff always talks about the UFOs engaging in what he calls signature
management, where they.
Control what they sort of look like or appear to be in optical and radar and that sort of thing.
And so maybe that's happening with the beings themselves. And so who knows?
One thing that I've learned over the decades is suspend judgment, man. At this point,
anything's possible. I don't know what's going on. I would love to know what's going on.
I don't either.
And I, and I want you guys to understand, like, I don't put,
something out into the public. If I don't believe it's highly likely that it happened. I'm not out
there just trying to, I really don't. I care about integrity. I care about perception.
You're the opposite of a grifter. A grifter doesn't start valeting cars and then makes
the thing on the side because he's so passionate about it. What are you talking about? When there
is no market for the thing in the early 2000s.
Once I pay back my investors, I always put my films on free platforms. Like free.
No, you just, you just told me before you started rolling.
Your dream is to buy the phenomenon back. So how are you a grifter? You want to buy your own
footage back? Cause that feels more authentic. It's crazy. Yeah. Anyway. So yeah, that's just
ridiculous. No, but it is these things. Same with the, with this thing in Peru, with these mummies,
like sometimes when the thing is staring you in the face, you think it's too good to be true,
but maybe, maybe it's just, you know, Jim Semivan, who's very high up at the CIA. He said,
said something, he was like, most of this stuff is a personal experience.
Yeah.
Says most of this stuff is just hidden in plain sight. And that's the conclusion that I've
come to, uh, again, despite my so funny, wouldn't it? Yeah. Right. What that it's just,
it's just there. Yeah. I was at the airport a couple of years ago and I was flying to Arizona
for a conference or something. And I, I get up to the gate and I was like, I left my sunglasses
in the car. It's like, I can't leave without my sunglasses. It's like, ah, I had to go back to
security. I go all the way out of the car. Ah, my sunglasses aren't there. I was like,
crap, guess where they were. Where? On my face. Yeah.
They're right there.
Yeah. Sometimes it's just right. Staring right there. But what, what is, did you,
did you probe Bigelow more and you say, what did you, you know, what'd you mean exactly by
I talked about the implications. Well, I did talk to him about the implications of, of disclosure,
the complications of disclosure a little bit, but in terms of them walking among us,
I wasn't ready for it. I honestly wasn't, I was like, you know, who's this guy? I don't know, man.
I, I, I, I couldn't dismiss it entirely just because of his position. He's probably invested
more money in research with nids and all SAP and a tip and all the various different people that
he's worked with. Um, so I couldn't like, I didn't categorically dismiss it, but I kind of put it,
I compartmentalize it and put the back of my head and, but as time went by and I learned more about
the phenomenon, I started thinking, man, maybe he's right. Maybe they are right here, you know,
walking.
And among us, wouldn't that be, wouldn't that be funny? You know, it's like,
you know, it's right under our noses. There it is in plain sight. And that seems to make
more sense to me because a lot of people go, you know, and I get people go, oh, well, you're just,
you know, you're concluding, you know, it's extraterrestrial. I was like, no, actually,
I didn't say that. And I've never said that. I really don't know what they are.
Well, with a guy who is, uh, transporting this being in this, you know, in the military,
uh, cargo driver or whatever he goes,
I'll show you the email.
I want to see that email.
Yeah. Sorry. Go ahead.
But he says, uh, he says it was, you know, it was told to him, like there was somebody who
was questioning him. What'd you see? And he says, I don't know what I saw, you know, it was like a
burnt human being or something. Cause he was trying to be cool as if he didn't see anything.
And the guy goes, it was super natural.
They focused on me with this older military guy. He looked me right in the eyes and asked what I
had seen.
I said, I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't
know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I said, I think
it was a burnt man or something.
He said, no, you didn't see that. I don't know if he thought I was trying to deceive him,
you know, like he knows, but he just doesn't want to talk about it.
It was then that he stated that what I had witnessed was a particular thing.
Yeah. Super natural.
Super natural. Yeah.
I was very funny.
I was very funny in the edit room. Cause I, I edit my own movies and that line just really
stuck with me and I really wanted it to, I really wanted it to, to hit with the audience. And so I,
I had, I did all the, uh, subtitles in the film and I did it at my pacing cause I'm a slow reader.
And I always frustrates me when I'm watching a film with subtitles, when they come on too fast,
I'm like, ah, you're going too fast, slow down. So I tried to like do one line whenever I could
two lines, most primarily one line. And when it came to super, cause he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he,
And when it came to super, cause he goes, this is military X talking about, with the general
meeting that he had with a general, after he driven this creature from various places,
humanities, ultimately Campinas and he's like, uh, he goes, no, no, it's not what you saw.
What you saw was super natural. And so I put super and then a beat later, natural,
as he said it on the text. And then the other guy that I worked with at Boris,
he changed it to have them both come on at the same time. And I went,
no no no no boris that was intentional i want that word because it's memorable right yes it's
a it's a cool it's a moment in the movie super natural yeah yeah yeah sounds like a shampoo
commercial or something right yeah exactly um yeah yeah i mean yeah it's sort of remarkable and and
we we don't know you know what these beings are and you know even on the on the i keep going back
to these peruvian mummies but they had these um like osmium and cadmium implants like on their
heads and you know i was just i was playing around i was asking chibi chat gpt you know what
these things might be adaptive for and it's like maybe they could create this local
electromagnetic field which would define how the beings are perceived or like modulate you know
in other words affect the environment around them yeah yeah it's crazy who knows i remember
what's his name uh i'll think of it a second he was a nasa employee
he analyzed photographs maccabee was it something maccabee bruce maccabee yeah bruce maccabee
he wrote fbi ufos and the fbi or something yeah but he primarily did photographic analysis and
he said to me years ago because i was like why are all the pictures blurry like ah you know and
people criticize that all the time and he's like if they're not blurry and they have a defined
clear edge this is 20 plus years ago he goes that's when you should be suspicious because there's some
kind of weird field around the propulsion we feel that causes a slight distortion and so you'll
always get slightly fuzzy edges and all that stuff i was like wow yeah wow that's interesting you
know i know it's coming from a guy phd like you know you have these lensing effects from
the gravitational yeah bubble it was explained really well in age of disclosure which i thought
you know yeah i mean red shifts or blue shifts yeah and uh you know tip my hat to to dan farah and lou
elizondo that was an exquisite accomplishment everyone can criticize how a film's put together
but trust me as a filmmaker myself uh i think that's going to help move the needle i i was very
impressed you know people like rubio and and james clapper and all coming forward and putting their
necks out so um i'm i'm excited about the times and i feel like moment of contact new revelations
of alien encounters i don't know the timing seems to be perfect because like dan farah's film age of
disclosure with lou elizondo i don't know the timing seems to be perfect because like dan farah's film age of disclosure with lou elizondo
is kind of everything that our film isn't and our film is everything their film isn't right so you
make these extraordinary claims you know and then you're we're providing an extraordinary case yes
yeah because this is an example one's top down and one's bottoms up do you know what i'm saying
right so i think that it's a really good i think the timing and the pressure that i felt to get
because i didn't know when age of disclosure was going to come out i'd heard it get paired it was
delayed whatever reasons and so the fact that it came out and then like you know six weeks later
the timing is going to be perfect yeah i think the stars are starting to align and i think that
we can really get some traction in terms of like and i think you know regardless of what you think
about the current administration i think if ever there was a time for full disclosure yeah i think
it's more likely to happen with him than anybody else yeah no i i agree he's he's more likely to
do something out of left field rip the band-aid off yeah yeah yeah because by the administration
i was so disappointed like rush came out during the bite administration it's like you're not even
addressing it well but the biden administration the problem with the biden administration okay
right now maybe you know you could argue that trump has too much agency or something with biden
he wasn't it was a headless administration it was literally the whole thing was just a bureaucracy
yeah because you had you have a guy who's had dementia yeah who and so then you're like who's
actually running oh is it jake sullivan maybe his chief of staff and then like what's he up to we
didn't elect him like what's the deal so
most dismissive nothing's going to get done in that context i felt it was the most dismissive
administration in history on the phenomenon and on everything yeah if you believe that
america is headed in the right direction then that was the right admin this you got a lot of
volatility maybe but it's like some sort of hail mary where you might get some movement or something
but i just feel like it's going to happen in this administration more than any other i really do
yeah yeah yeah and i'm and we're going to be doing well you have all these truth and transparency
initiatives i mean one interesting thread is like tulsi and clapper kind of hate each other i don't
know i didn't know that yeah yeah so tulsi's the current dni and like they're going after clapper
because she seems pretty amazing i love tulsa yeah she seems like amazing she seems i'm a fan i think
she's great i think she's she's an honest earnest actor i think she's very brave and um yeah i i you
know pray for her it takes unconventional to get this stuff done it does yeah so um but she doesn't
clapper um because she says that clapper was involved in russiagate and this whole kind of
you know um planting stuff on trump's calling the russian asset or whatever so i guess what i would
say to the current dni is like okay like do you want like clapper or any of these guys eating your
lunch on this very important issue or do you want to get in front of the issue good idea why would
you want these guys to get credit when you can get the credit exactly i mean honestly you would go
look i interviewed senator harry reid yeah and love the guy i hate him whatever he was he
spearheaded something that was incredible right yeah yeah and he stood up for lou alessandro and
i'm very grateful for that but i asked him this question i recently unearthed it because i didn't
put it in the phenomenon and i said like what would you tell whatever president it was what
would you tell the president of the united states about this topic and he shows don't be afraid
don't be afraid to take it on head-on like don't be afraid to admit that this is up to
israel like and i think that's really important because everyone that i've interviewed including
the governor including senators and members of congress it was the best thing to their career
they thought it was going to be the opposite effect right but in actuality and i even
interviewed the former governor of new mexico who's a democrat richardson and he goes you know
quite honestly james one of the few things that i ever did in my political career was looking into
the ufo phenomenon particularly the roswell crash he goes you wouldn't believe the level of support
both parties no it's it's you look at one of the only bipartisan things you look at luna burchette
burleson like all these guys yeah are it's become their like number one issue and they are going on
podcast tours they're talking about it constantly yeah and they're all pumped yeah so democrats and
republicans working together is so beautiful to see thank god they're working for the people
yeah so but it it's clearly good for their career it's not yes bad for them that's exactly right
yeah that's exactly right yeah no they're getting notoriety and people want the truth yeah they do
and they should get it yeah like i don't care man if it's a little scary whatever yeah don't hide
don't treat us like children don't hide the truth like it's so like you you you know so much and i
know what i know whatever you know more than me well not really but but you know what i know i
know right because i went out you know but um we regardless of it i think that every man woman and
child has a right to have a right to have a right to have a right to have a right to have a right to
know what the bigger picture is stop treating us like children like it frustrates me to no end
when you see like statements made you know it's starting to be less so
these days satan is they're so clearly like clash with reality like
the crash test dummies in roswell if you've looked in you know a modicum of research into
the roswell case you'd be like you'd laugh that right out of the room right yeah all these bluish
dummies like and that happened like way later and then project mogul like project mogul is like later
and they're same balloons but they're stringed together to make a bigger balloon like if you
look at all the facts that's just it's like a slap in the face anybody who knows anything about it you
know it's like and it's just i've had it like could you just please can we just have some
transparency on this like that's one of the reasons why i'm working so hard like you know
i'm pushing now harder than ever like i've cranked out since 2020 i've put my weight on the ground and
out the phenomenon then i put out moment of contact then i put out the program now i put
out a new version moment of contact which covering all the congressional hearings really quickly you
saw and i'm doing something else that i'll be cranking that out in under a year because i feel
like now is not the time to let up as much as i want to go spend more time with my family and i do
believe me it's very painful like to be away from my son and i'm missing so many things but i feel
like my my whole career has kind of culminated to this moment right now and i feel like we all as a
community need to work together need to be kinder to one each other need to respect one each other
particularly with those that we disagree with i really mean that like because we're stronger
together yeah speak speaking of people who did not hold back on the truth uh paula 14 astronaut edgar
mitchell yeah you met him as well right yes i did and he came back and he was just from his moon
you know
excursions and he was just completely adamant that uh alien life is real i think he was in
touch with various components of the government maybe kind of legacy crash retrieval programs yes
himself yes and he had that he had that memo at his house yeah tell me about this memo well it's
the uh oh you're talking about the wilson david yeah you know yeah of course yeah i covered that
yeah which is strange that he even had that memo which is which is documenting eric davis in the
parking lot talking to admiral thomas j wilson
who's head of j2 joint chiefs should be in charge of all military technology in the government at
the time and he's still in the 90s he's still around you know he was there was some people
that wanted to subpoena him into into a skiff yeah and he goes and i talked to the people that
subpoenaed him yeah and they said he goes he goes sure i'll come into the skiff but i'm gonna tell
you the same thing i'm telling you right here that i'm gonna tell you in the skiff so if you want to
waste my time and yours let's go that's crazy isn't that funny because in that document you have him
but he said he would deny it yeah he's like if this ever comes out i'll deny deny deny yeah but
let me tell you something interesting about edgar edgar mitchell and i was really close i mean i
saw i would call him all the time for advice and he participated i was interviewing him in my 20s
i went to his house in the middle of the interview and i was also friends with buzz aldrin's sister
faye ann potter very close i used to go to her house i used to look at all the behind the scenes
photographs and the moon landings and all the stuff and she would tell she said that the nasa
were all given some kind of pill that they would die if anything happened and also like wait wait
they would be given a pill they gave a pill like where if they have to kill themselves if they
missed the if they missed the earth sorry if they missed the moon and they shot off into the space
they were gonna they would have something they could die yeah they could in other words they
would have to have a slow death they could kill us that's what she told me fan potter she showed me
all these pictures and and that and that if if uh if if if neil armstrong came out and anything
buzz was not supposed to play the hero he's supposed to leave his ass on the moon and get back
meet up with as it was at collins that they michael j collins michael j collins yeah
and so she she told me that she also told me that he had some ufo encounter on the way to the moon
um oh i know yeah and one of my biggest regrets was well i have a lot of them but you told that
story on the last yeah i was that fayenne potter never i never got her on camera talking about her
her brother but you chased buzz aldrin down and did it and and you said i want to interview you
about ufos and then he goes what did what would my testimony do when i was watching joe rogan talk
about and i respect his opinion that's totally fine but i was personally friends with a number
of people that landed on the moon and i got great detail and could i have been deceived sure i could
have been but i think about like when joe's like yeah look at the three of them sitting right after
they landed on the moon i was thinking well that's the look on their faces of people that maybe they
had a ufo encounter on the way to the moon like fan potter yeah that's and they had to shut up
and they had to shut up about it that's the third option that's the third option that's the third option
yeah because you have you know you know beatrice villarreal no oh yeah yeah yeah yeah you
interviewed her not too long ago yeah she's amazing she's spotted thousands 10 000 plus
transients every year from in the palmar observatory which is the most prominent observatory
and this was between 1949 and 1957 these things aren't sun streaks they're not you know asteroids
comets meteors obviously they're they're not satellites because they're pre-sputnik in 1957 and
they're like mirror-like light reflecting objects which are what all the cia documents describe ufos
as in the late 40s and early 50s and they're in geosynchronous orbit and so you you yeah and so
you have to and they and they sort of pop up yeah and so you wonder when you leave you know the the
van allen belt you know when you leave the protective magnetosphere of the earth do you just
encounter tons and tons of ufos and if you look at bluegill triple prime which was the first
we cut a hole in the magnetosphere of the earth with the you know uh we were trying to see if we
could puncture the van allen belt guess what came out ufo material and harold maumgren this
presidential advisor i'm so glad you got to him isn't that wild and he said he was holding the
pieces the uf the pieces of the uf it was it was an accidental shoot down he reached for
some stuff sitting on his desk these are things that have come down but debris or images
debris wow wow that's amazing so are we just surrounded
by ufos and and maybe that's the secret maybe the you know the the neil armstrong cryptic speech
about you know uh the the layers uh concealing the truth there are great ideas undiscovered
breakthroughs available to those who can remove one of truth's protective layers
are in fact the idea that once you you get past the van allen belt you actually encounter just a
ufo and then you have okay another one very well could be the case and all i can tell you is that i
was good friends with edgar mitchell i went to his house i sat down with him in the middle of a ufo
interview i was like i i i'm sorry to ask this of you i know you get asked this all the time
but what was it like to go to the moon i closed my eyes and i listened to every every detail
but if that guy was lying he was a damn good liar like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
just me in the room with him and the sound guy or audio guy you know i'd have to dismiss him i'd
have to dismiss fan potter i'd have to say like i'm open to it though so here no here here's where
i land yeah sorry yeah i didn't mean to interrupt you but no you didn't interrupt me at all i'm just
answering i'm just kind of responding to how where you're at is like i i think the presentation of
the first apollo mission was clearly manicured and sanitized can i tell you something about that yeah
i talked to edgar michelle because a lot of this stuff was coming out in the 90s yeah and they were
questioning the moon landing stuff and i was like yo what do you think about all this like imagery
yeah he goes james it wouldn't surprise me he goes we had hostile blood cameras with no viewfinders
gardening gloves on yeah and like the whole world was watching he goes it wouldn't surprise me if
they recreated some imagery that they could fall back on just in case for sure the biggest most
expensive endeavor in the history of mankind and like and he goes that wouldn't surprise me but he
he goes i walked on the moon i swear to god yeah yeah and like if we had one person and maybe we do
but i don't know of anyone i don't know how many people were involved in putting a man on the moon
but i'm i'm assuming it was in the tens of thousands if not more and not one person from
high level well walking on the moon what way has anybody got that you know no no no but what oh
involved in the program the apollo program how many a few hundred thousand a few hundred thousand yeah
so has anyone from that few hundred thousand come forward and said it didn't happen yes but but yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i didn't know that yes but no no apollo astronauts but some people
within the nest some people and yeah in fact there's this guy who rogan talked about on the show
where he like did this whole review and he okay you know um oh i i i saw that broadcast danny
danny danny and you had the danny jones yeah you know but but bart cybrel is he's not associated
with the program itself but there are there are people who were and there's the gus gray
shim thing right he died the next day and yeah there's a lemon on the thing there's some weird
facts and you could are you know if you think that the ufo program is involves like so many people
like there's an argument that could be made that the only thing that would need to be faked would
be like mission control and if you could fake mission control you know like all the parts
suppliers and all the people like doing kind of the ancillary kind of peripheral you have
you know like the the spokes of the wheel so to speak in the operation they could easily
be lied to but i i yeah i still shake out i do you know i think we attempted and then like you
know i did there's to me i following the evidence something about the presentation of the whole
thing clearly sanitized yeah and i think the video's weird the two light the two light sources
that you know the there's some anomalies the the flag yeah the you know this is just like there's
a there's a lot there's you know no dust on the lunar lander i talked to a guy who's a scientist
he worked on that cheesy tv show i did ben uh is the guy and i was asking him about the moon landing
stuff and he's like well you know and he's told geeked out scientists like he's like ah you know
we could see the the laser we put a laser on some of the things that we left on the surface of the
moon yeah the reflectors yeah reflectors and we have stuff up there and you can see them you can
put it you can put up the reflector with the with the rover yeah but so something went to the moon
according to this guy ben for sure something well we put rovers to them up to the moon no question
no question about that yeah no question yeah yeah yeah yeah no anyway you know i again going
back to the ufo phenomenon every time i say something's impossible therefore you know it
can't be there for it isn't i've been proven wrong yeah yeah i have to open i have to be like from
what i know i believe we went to the moon could i be wrong i could be wrong and i'm not going to sit
there and say i'm you know i know what i'm talking about because i really don't well maybe the more
interesting middle path would be their ufos along the way to the moon and it's surrounded or something
who is clinton's chief of staff and you know who i interviewed oh really interesting i interviewed
him yeah what was that like it was great because he talked about you know they so uh lawrence
spellman rockefeller who put together the briefing document for uh dignitaries and high-level
politicians and all that stuff i think it was like a global thing uh he apparently put
significant pressure on the clinton administration to look into ufos and to the point where he said
if you don't do it i'm gonna i'm gonna publish publicize the fact that you won't do it i'm gonna
put it on the cover of every magazine across the country you know blah blah blah apparently whoa
threaten him a little bit and uh and so podesta said all right well the clinton administration
said all right pick a case that we should look into and they picked roswell because roswell
obviously if it happened right and so uh and then according to podesta clinton was not happy
with the answers they were getting they were getting the run around the president united
states was getting the runner yeah no that's right and then podesta
basically entered a you know multi-decade long personal search for this whole thing and cool
that he spoke out at one of the uh national press club events i think that leslie kane was involved
with that way back back back when maybe yeah oh maybe i believe it well they're they're emails
that have since been deleted between him and tom delong about ufos and these are this came out
over wikileaks but you know i think this this exists in the form of screenshots or maybe the
way back machine or something and it's him uh meeting with a guy who's been working with the
guy named bob fish who um i think might have worked at aerospace corporation and el segundo
across from spacex this sort of mysterious federally funded research and development center
think tank and they're talking about fast walkers and they're talking about the things in space fast
walkers and and you to this day you cannot use the freedom of information act on fast walkers you
know uh john greenwald tried to do that he's like the you know ufo foia guy and and was rejected and
then it was like what was it like for me uh you know i think i think it's um it's it's quite simple
for them to be able to you know navigate a space like that and do whatever it takes to get there
and to have a goodidentified inner space like the one at the center of the earth or um the pg
and the kind of like순
you have the malmgren thing where you puncture the van allen radiation belt and that ufo material
comes out you have a tic tac you have the you have it's uh it just material that he held is
all we know lawrence preston geist who ran the atomic energy commission albuquerque branch did
they scoop it out of the ocean they did scoop it out of the ocean yeah and uh general uh general
starboard um who was there flew back to headquarters at like 4 a.m that night and
william ogle who was overseeing the whole thing for los alamos uh special projects
division writes about it and all all of this is like public it's it's it's really insane
and yeah and you have this kind of public fight between um uh you have on the one hand jeffrey
cruikshank who's like a nuclear expert ufo researcher in australia and um then d dean
johnson and uh uh merrick von rennenkamp they say it's the booster but he's sure that it can't be
the booster it has to be some sort of anomalous ufo material but you have video of something
coming out of and then and then you have this other video
where you're talking about the ufo material and you're talking about the ufo material and you're
talking about the ufo material and you're talking about the ufo material where it looks like there's a
where it looks like there's a
where it looks like there's a white triangle superimposing the ufo coming
white triangle superimposing the ufo coming
white triangle superimposing the ufo coming out of the nuclear blast plume wow it's
out of the nuclear blast plume wow it's
out of the nuclear blast plume wow it's crazy it's crazy and i that's where
crazy it's crazy and i that's where
crazy it's crazy and i that's where the debate gets a little above my head
the debate gets a little above my head
the debate gets a little above my head as far as you know the merrick and d dean
as far as you know the merrick and d dean
as far as you know the merrick and d dean johnson versus the
johnson versus the
crookshank i don't know if that but we need more eyes on that it's an important thing when you
interviewed malcolm yeah and i was watching the interview i was like i'm so glad you got to him
uh i was thinking to myself and this is just me speculating whatever i was thinking like about
that launch of the atlas rocket at vandenberg circa 1964 64. uh with the with the with the
dummy warhead on it right no wonder if it's true what malgrom says right they detonated that up into
was it subspace or yeah it was a yeah high altitude nuclear yeah a little subspace yeah right yeah so
if that's the case no wonder why they were shooting at the dummy warhead according to jacobs
right the footage that he captured if i if one of my comrades was shot down by one of these silly
like missile launch with a nuclear you know what i mean like i'd probably shoot it out of the sky
too which is exactly
exactly what they did i was like wow that makes sense no wonder why they shot it out of the sky
yes it took some of their people down yes and then and then you then you have this disabling nukes
shooting that out of the sky like that's pretty phenomenal yeah it's really phenomenal and lou
elizondo said he saw that footage yeah i know he says he saw that footage and he says he knows where
it is and i'm like luke get that thing out we saw the video that's crazy because that's what i was
going to ask
you he said he was like i think lou has seen the video so you've seen the video
yeah so you know this is a real thing yeah oh my god is it is the video do you still have the video
or i don't have it was it was in pentagon with all my other files when when the pentagon said
they deleted everything of course we know they really didn't because really after they oh yeah
oh yeah oh my god you know where everything is and then and then when i talked to a buddy of mine
apparently somebody went in and they they cleaned everything out but what they don't realize is that
they have the best computer we know that you can use your computer on is it's actually a laptop
you're using a computer that's on the internet which is a laser you're using a lot of footages
and a lot of backups in a whole lot of places at that okay the problem is if i say right now
they'll go and nope mysteriously a bunch of people's computers will wind up disappearing
tomorrow so i'm just gonna wait until the right time and uh you know that stuff is alive and well
we need to provide people like lou and grush immunity so they can give us all those details
Yeah. And let's reverse it. You have to say everything you know, or you're in trouble.
Everything you know that doesn't compromise some specific vehicle you're working on that's
going to confer a tactical advantage to Russia or China, all the science, let it out. And flip it
and say, if you don't say everything you know, you're going to get in trouble. Let's do that.
I mean, you know, look, we've got nothing to lose, everything to gain. Obviously,
there are certain aspects of national security. I understand that they don't want to get in the
hands of the wrong people. I get it. You know, if the accounts would be believed that Russia's
obviously trying to figure this out. But it's like nuclear trade secrets. We don't let out
the trade secrets, but nuclear science is taught at universities across the United States. This
should be treated the exact same way. Totally agree. I totally agree. And like, you know,
like I said earlier in the show, if you don't believe Lou, if you don't believe Grush,
you don't believe Hal, you don't believe Eric Davis or any of these other alleged whistleblowers,
let's give them immunity and let's put
him on the stand. Well, that's Eric Davis in your recent moment of contact. He's asking for that. He
says, literally, give me a blanket immunity and I will say everything I know. Yep. He'll testify
tomorrow in an open, under oath. Under oath. To a bipartisan group of lawmakers, openly for the
whole world to see. And he says he has all this data on crash retrievals, alien bodies. Criticize
him all you want. He says, I swear on my family's life that this is the truth. He said on my
children's life. On my children's life. Where's the proof? We have alien
spaceships in our possession. We have bodies. Where and why can't I get the specifics to verify
those claims? If the president of the United States issued an executive order that absolves
me of all of my TSSCI NDAs, NDAs are non-disclosure agreements. Those are the agreements we have to
sign for every compartment in our SCI clearances. So if the president waives or
absolves my obligation to those NDAs and I get subpoenaed by Congress, somebody on Capitol Hill,
some committee, either in the Senate or the House or the both, to reveal everything I know
that I learned from my investigations, both unclassified and classified, into the legacy UAP
crash retrieval and hardware reverse engineering and NHI programs, I would do so. If I could be
waived from that or absolved in some fashion by presidential order,
and if I could be waived from that, I would do so. And if I could be waived from that,
I would do so. And if I could be waived from that, I would do so. And if I could be waived from that,
Congress subpoenas me, yes, I would go and tell them everything I know. This reality is very hard,
very physical, very real. And this type of evidence, you can't come by in the open literature.
It's not public, it's classified. And I can't discuss what it was. But I can tell you, yeah,
it's a crash retrieval. There's a craft. And there's alien bodies. That's all I can say about
it. You swear on your life that you saw those pictures? Oh, I swear on my life and everybody's
my children's life. So I swear on my life and everybody's my children's life. So I swear on
my life and everybody's my children's life. So I swear on my life and everybody's my children's life.
Yeah, I'm absolutely telling you the truth. I saw the evidence, and it's stark.
Just wild. So yes, that needs-
Thank you for remembering that. That's a great line.
Absolutely.
I swear on my children's life. Who's going to say that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I mean-
Who would say that?
You're either a sick person-
You're a psychopath?
Or you're telling the truth.
Yeah. And speaking of the idea of-
You're all speaking of psychopaths. No, I'm kidding.
Speaking of psychopaths, yeah. No, speaking of your mentioning of Bob Jacobs, Vandenberg,
case in 64, where you have this dummy nuclear warhead getting shot out of the sky.
Yes.
This is where it gets really trippy, because either they are defending against some sort
of incursion in their airspace, or they're actually provoking some of this occurring.
So this is really strange. But Malmgren on his deathbed told Pippa, his daughter,
that he saw an interview from one of the surviving beings from Roswell,
and that-
Taped? What's that?
Taped? A taped interview?
A taped interview.
Okay, okay. So he saw, sorry, just like-
Yeah, yeah, not live, sorry.
Abundance of clarity.
No, no, a taped interview.
So Malmgren on his deathbed-
Yes.
Told his daughter, Pippa-
Who's alive and a friend of mine, and-
That he watched-
A tape.
A taped interview with a captured alien.
With a captured alien. And guess what? Guess what the alien said? The alien gave them the idea
to do blue-
A tape.
Blue-gill triple prime, and have this specialized x-ray system that would not only be used as missile
defense, but be used to take out UFO material out of the sky, to be reverse engineered. So it's-
That, isn't that-
Like a deal?
Like giving him information as to how to retrieve the material. So you get into this weird thing
where like-
It's better than you say that on camera.
I know.
Well, there's so much-
Why would his daughter make that up?
No, why would she make it up?
That doesn't make any sense.
Well, it's all these things, and there was kind of a takedown of the, you know,
there's all these people criticizing Malmgren afterwards. They said that-
Easy to do, right?
Well, yeah, well, I can also-
I mean, when they're dead.
Sure. I can also crush all their arguments. They literally, you know, this is, you know,
I don't want to be too tribalistic. Like, I do think all of this stuff has to be thought about
probabilistically, and like, if there are good points, please make them against-
Yeah.
This guy. There are no sacred cows. He's making an extraordinary claim. But this guy was an elite
statesman who knew people, you know, at the top of the chain, like literally, you know, knew Nixon
personally. He was LBJ, JFK, Nixon, and Ford, you know, presidential advisor. And he said-
He's not an anybody.
He was a little bit junior in the JFK administration and was more, you know, in touch
with Shriver. But like, yeah, was not-
Was not a nobody. You know, talks about stories with the, you know, Russian foreign minister,
Dobrynin. His mentor was Richard Bissell, who founded Area 51 and was the deputy director of
the CIA, the number two at the entire CIA. We have diaries of his that say, meeting with Bissell,
all over his diary, his journal. So he definitely knew Bissell. If he had gotten his Q clearance
through the CIA, there's no way to use the Freedom of Information Act against it.
Is that the highest level clearance?
Q?
Yes. Well, I think there may possibly, you know, UAP group talks about different designations
within Q clearance.
Like a SAP?
Like, I think there's this like special foreign intelligence designation. So the CIA works with
the DOE and there's a counterintel division actually of the CIA that like works with the
Department of Energy. And I think there are different Q clearances you can have.
Because DOE, sorry, Department of Energy, because I was told, I think it was Chris Mellon was telling
us that they hide things because anything nuclear would be national security.
Yeah, alfit
secret so if you're an aerospace contractor you don't need some sort of official clearance
designation you know you're just automatic you're automatically that is under that envelope
or that umbrella yeah wow so so so that you have this this you know this blog came out trying to
debunk malmgren but if he got his skill clearance through the cia they'd have no idea uh that you
know they you can't use the freedom of information against that this was uh at the time where you
know not official covers this idea of being a knock for the cia was like rampant like a ton
of these guys and he was at a federal funded uh research and development center um called
the ida the the institute for defense analysis which has instituted every or has helped with
every single missile defense system that the us has built since then since bluegill triple prime
and he said in a 2024 interview before he interviewed with me that his work at the
idea was actually a cover for what he was doing for the national security council in the white
house
so you have all these arguments that oh he's just at the ida he's like some junior guy like no he's
already talked about this and his mentor by the way was extremely high up at the cia this is what
you're really good at you're really good at putting these complex pieces of the puzzle together it's
like oh this is like this that makes sense and this is over here it's like duh well it's important
totally important are you kidding me and i love the deep dives that you do just like when i put
the maps up for virginia this was here this witness turns out to be there it's like oh my gosh it all
lines up you have a full picture you have a full picture just like what you're doing on the inside
like you're creating that full picture which is mandatory for what you do like when i'm in the
field putting the piece of the puzzle together when we met italo it made perfectly good sense
because we knew for dec for decades that it went initially alive to regional yeah right
then it was humanitas now we have we have to get to humanitas we're working on that now
like you know i mean you're putting the piece and they're all it's all painting the picture right
like it's incredible just like what you're doing yeah you're putting all the pieces of puzzles
together where are the different it's incredible and i i'm always impressed when i watch how you
do that like i'm doing it in my little way and you're doing you know we're all doing yeah no
it's really cool to watch that was like there was a couple of interview deep dive interviews
that you did that i was just like holy smokes you know it was very impressive yeah with hal or was
hal um uh eric davis oh yeah yeah that that whole thing just the deep dives and stuff that
you do is very impressive to watch well i'm excited it's fun to watch all this stuff accelerate
we're in this together yes we support each other yes i remind people out there that to to we're
stronger together be kind particularly those you disagree with it's okay that we disagree that's
fine yes nothing wrong with that yes and uh you know i'm not out here screaming et from the hill
top
I'm not i i'm i'm curious i want to know desperately and it's what's behind it all
it's easy to it's easier and lazier to impugn somebody's motives and say that they're a bad
actor than to actually tackle the substance or give them a platform so they can they can cough
up the goods yeah exactly why not yeah yeah exactly yes so i was going to criticize you
and i'm not gonna you know uh i'm not gonna you know continue like people give these breadcrumbs
i think about like david grosch for instance you know he comes forward it's like all right well
you know what you know extraordinary claims if you want to say provo you know give us the
extraordinary evidence but why not create that platform for david rush to build to do that he's
refrained he's restrained he's yeah yeah his safety his family safety like he could get locked
up i mean those are real concerns that these people have yeah you think he's gonna fall on
his face okay give him the one-time clearance let him go that's exactly right like or put him out
to testify at a rose like what why the hell would you let him go out there with a knife in his face
you know i mean like that's like the way i feel for him i mean you know that's the way i feel for him
you know i mean like that's the way i feel for him we're all ain't he's fine i mean like i think you found this
oath like why wouldn't we do that yeah you know so yeah anyway i yeah have you okay yes sir you
got i got more for you because you've got you've seen so much history so have you ever seen a
saucer and a hanger i wish are you kidding me come on because of all people if i was on the
inside i'd say i'd say james i can either you've done you've done your work okay i wish have you
ever been taken into a skit yes you have yes have you ever seen anything interesting in a skiff yes
yes what did you see i i can't talk about that because they asked me not to but i said if that
goes out that's not going to look good for you guys that's that flies in the face of all the
testimony that i've ever heard so not as good as things you've seen in the open source yeah it was
really funny too because i i just put out the program and i met with a number of government
insiders that are intel decided excuse me they're
just
described the exact computer uh the computer that has access to all the good you know what i mean
yeah ufo files and stuff like that yeah and i was sitting there looking at it in the skiff
and i'm thinking if i can have just a few minutes with that computer you know what i mean yeah no it
was really crazy i was one of kind of a pinch yourself moment when i was in there with john
klaus klauski the the new head of arrow which i liked him actually i thought he was cool i did
way cooler than sean kirkpatrick that's for sure yeah yeah sean kirkpatrick man that guy like i've
maybe that guy was read in or something i don't know that guy was i don't trust that guy at all
i don't either john koskowski was really nice guy i looked him in the eyes he seemed like a sincere
honest nice guy i did not get a bad vibe from him but i was talking openly because i was like
whatever i have to lose they know who i am like i was talking about rua i was talking about you
know virginia i was talking about sakura all these different cases and i was like you know
you know you're going to draw the conclusion after all the other you've exhausted the
every other possibility that we are dealing with a small percentage of probably non-human
intelligence right i mean you know that like what's the plan to tell the public
and they're both very quiet and um john goes he goes you know james he ain't very soft
like non he i liked him i got a good vibe from him and he's like you know james i can't part my hair
without the approval of the dod whoa and then he goes and you can quote me on that
okay you're quoting him but i was in the skiff and um it was just like in the movies
you know i went in i went in it was not too far from the pentagon and i had to get a 48
hour background check which i passed thank god and then i had to go through all the security
take everything off and go through all the oh my gosh that took forever and then they had these
like glass tube like things i felt like it was a star trek or something they were i think they
went to the ceiling or they were pretty high up glass tubes and you walk up to it and
And once that opens and you step in and then that closes and another one
opens and now you're in the inside.
And then I go to a locker.
They probably got my phone data and I took all my,
all my electronics and I put it in the locker and,
you know,
and then we went to a big door with a thing and you know,
just like you almost like a bank vault looking door and opened up.
And it was a,
it was a,
it was,
I thought it was going to be like a kind of a small room,
but it was a huge,
it was like the whole,
the whole office area was all one big skiff.
Right.
And they walked me in there and I was just like,
Oh my God,
this is crazy.
Actually before,
before,
uh,
we went into the skiff and I just gone through security.
I had this badge and I was like,
I really want a picture of this badge.
Cause I just want to,
you know,
I want to have it from memory.
So I,
okay,
can I use the bathroom?
You know?
Oh,
sure.
It's,
I went in the bathroom,
click,
took a picture of the badge,
which I have.
Cause I don't know.
It's,
it's not illegal,
right?
Take a picture of the badge.
But anyway,
they take me in this,
down this hallway.
There's a bunch of different cubicles and take me down this
hallway.
And then there was like a door on my right and a door on my
left.
The door on my right was closed.
The door on the left was open.
And there was like a,
I don't know if it was a round table or if it was slightly
like,
um,
uh,
what do you call,
um,
oblong or whatever.
But anyway,
there were four or five people,
a couple of girls,
a couple of guys in suits,
nicely dressed,
sitting there.
And,
and they said,
Hey,
wait right here.
And like I said,
I had a door to my,
on my right.
And I had this open door on my left and I couldn't help
myself.
I was just like,
you know,
kind of listening to the other covers.
I just want,
I was scared.
What else am I supposed to do?
I stopped where they told me to stop.
And then,
and then they looked at me and they got up and they
closed the door.
Ah,
and then,
uh,
and then John Koskowski with another guy from OSI came
and,
and met with me and open,
open the door in that room.
And then we went inside there.
And that's when,
when we had,
I don't know,
maybe a 30 minute conversation.
And in that conversation,
was he admitting that the UFO stuff is real?
They didn't say no.
They didn't say yes.
They were just sat there quietly.
Okay.
Yeah.
Cause I was like this case or this case and this
case.
And they didn't.
And then they did say that the phenomenon was
mandatory viewing for anyone who worked for arrow.
Interesting.
Well,
that's cool.
Isn't that cool?
That's pretty awesome.
I was like,
wow.
Yeah.
That was a nice little,
you know,
I'm telling you,
you're doing,
there's much work there.
They're learning from you.
Are you ready?
There you go.
Nice.
I don't know.
I love my little T-shirt.
I got to buy one.
I know.
I'll give you some.
No,
I was the first time I went on Rogan.
I,
I was like,
I'm not going to be the guy who gives them a
T-shirt on camera.
I'm going to do it afterwards.
Yeah.
So I always do that.
You know what I mean?
So I give him a T-shirt afterwards on camera
is basically like,
here's an advertisement.
I was like,
Hey,
you know,
and,
uh,
and I don't even know,
I don't own the phenomenon anymore and none
of the proceeds go to me,
but I still want people to watch it.
Cause I'm very proud of that body of work and
everyone that's in the credits deserves it.
But,
um,
but I gave it to Joe Rogan and,
uh,
you know,
really appreciate.
And,
uh,
oh,
so,
you know,
when we went to dinner with Joe Rogan the
night before with Jacques Filet and one other
guy from his team,
well,
it was great,
man.
We,
we drank really nice wine.
It was five course.
Oh,
it was incredible meal.
Oh my Lord.
We had so much fun.
I was,
it was a wonderful,
Joe's such a nice guy,
man.
Like just really a nice guy.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't care what anybody says about you,
you meet him and you hang out with him.
This guy's cool.
Super cool.
Nice guy.
And super fulfilled.
And like humble and just kind and generous.
And anyway,
I got up from the meal and I went discreetly out
like I was going to the bathroom and I paid
for the meal.
Oh,
and it wasn't cheap.
And,
uh,
and,
and came back and he,
you know,
after like 21 minutes,
he's like,
Hey,
can,
you know,
can we get the bill here,
please?
And the guy goes,
it's been taken care of.
And Joe looks over at me and I got the impression
like nobody does that.
What did,
how did he react?
Well,
he was shocked.
He was like,
you,
you know,
Oh my God,
nobody,
you know,
it was like,
Oh,
but Hey man,
it's the least I could do.
Thank you.
You know,
anyway,
um,
but I gave him the t-shirt.
Yeah.
And two or three days later,
I could,
everyone's blowing me up.
Joe Rogan's wearing your t-shirt on his podcast.
And there he was rocking the phenomenon on his podcast.
How cool is that?
It's so cool.
You know what I mean?
He just did the same with the ours merch last week.
And it was just so,
it was so,
it's so nice of him.
It's so cool.
He has helped so many people.
He's created so many careers.
He has so many.
I'll give you an example.
When I,
I got an Uber ride,
uh,
when Joe,
Joe flew me in first class,
which is incredible.
Then I had a driver pick me up and the driver,
uh,
he was like,
Oh,
you're going on Joe.
Oh God,
I love that guy.
And I was like,
Oh,
and he goes,
let me tell you,
man,
I was really down on my luck and I was just,
things weren't going well.
And I was just really struggling.
And he goes,
I,
I was,
I was on to take Joe to some place and I got the address wrong.
And I,
I got him lost and I,
you know,
15 minutes longer than it should have been.
And I felt terrible.
He was,
you know,
Joe Rogan,
such an important guy.
He's got all this stuff going on and man,
I felt terrible.
And Joe's like,
Hey man,
wait here.
I got,
I'll be right back.
I need to go to this one location.
Come back.
And Joe came back and he tipped him like $2,000.
He gave him some huge tip and he goes,
that saved my life.
I was behind on my rent.
I was like really struggling financially.
He goes,
Joe did that for me.
And I'm a random stranger,
like just screwed up his,
his ride.
And I heard that's wild.
Yeah.
And I heard that from just about everybody that I encountered in the Austin area about
how Joe,
Joe would do a random act of kindness and generosity,
help people like,
no,
he is like,
he's like that.
He called me out of the blue and was like,
just super complimentary.
Like,
like just so nice.
And,
and yeah,
he's so generous.
And what else?
I mean,
there's that story of this miss path,
this comedian.
She,
I think right when COVID hit or whatever was struggling or whatever.
And she was like,
the only guy that called me,
it was Joe Rogan,
you know?
And like,
Oh really?
Yeah.
He really,
he really cares.
And I think.
He does care.
And,
and he really does sincerely care.
And you hear all those stories behind the scenes of people that have had encounters with him and has had nothing but nice things to say,
not nothing,
but nice things to say.
And I say the same thing.
Like I'm incredibly grateful for the exposure he's given all of us,
all of us.
I think he's more than anybody bent the timeline towards disclosure and even an interest in any of this.
No,
no question.
And it allows like more,
you know,
I find,
I think I'm,
I'm sort of this niche,
like,
you know,
compared to another thing that I really love about Joe is that Joe has president Trump on Joe has Bernie Sanders on.
Yeah.
Joe has opposing viewpoints.
He's kind to everybody.
Like he gives them a platform.
Cause I think like it's so easy nowadays,
like,
Oh,
you're on the left or you're on the right or you're in the middle or you're whatever.
And you know,
you're the,
you're the devil.
We disagree.
Therefore you're the devil.
And I just like,
that bothers me because I'm friends with all,
you're cool and you're a nice person.
We're good.
You know what I mean?
Like,
and I have friends with people that are both sides of the spectrum.
We would do,
we don't even care.
We're high five.
Yeah.
We're really close and tight with good PR.
You know what I mean?
Like,
I don't believe in the demonizing of someone just because they have a different viewpoint than you do.
That's just so wrong.
I know it's so wrong.
Yeah.
And the internet allows you to do that.
You,
you,
um,
compress somebody into this two D you're there.
Exactly.
You're,
you're like this avatar that like,
you know,
you're some evil,
like,
you know,
and you're not actually just like this full dimensional,
like you have a human being with like a family and like,
you know,
it's like,
we're all,
it's all good.
I know.
But then none of those people would say those things to your face,
you know,
it's just,
it's a keyboard warrior.
Very good point.
BS.
It's like,
yeah,
that is a very good point.
Yeah.
When you meet him,
like,
I always say like,
like I've said some things very rarely and particularly not publicly,
but I said,
I said,
this,
you know,
to this person's face,
I was like,
Hey,
you know,
I really hurt because of X,
Y,
and Z.
And I really appreciate it if you,
you know,
cause I feel like if I have an issue with anybody,
I'm going to tell,
say,
say it to their face.
Totally.
Cause that's the way it should be.
Yes.
I'm not going to sit there and like,
Oh wait,
he said this and no,
he's like,
I got an issue.
Let's hash it out.
I'm pissed off.
That's why.
And we all make mistakes.
Yes.
I piss people off inadvertently.
Of course.
You know,
like,
Oh shit,
I'm so sorry they were offended or I said the wrong thing.
And like,
Hey,
all you can do is go back and make an apology.
I'm really sorry.
I hope you forgive me.
And nine times out of 10 people are like,
you know what?
That's cool.
We're good.
Yeah.
It's all.
Yeah,
totally.
Yeah.
A hundred percent have.
Okay.
Have you ever been asked to bury a story?
Sort of,
sort of.
Okay.
What does that mean?
Like,
sort of like,
I've had like this,
this meeting never happened.
Okay.
We don't,
don't discuss any of the details that I just,
gave you.
And I feel like if I violated that trust,
I wouldn't get in the door with these people.
No,
you know what I mean?
Valuing relationships.
For sure.
Yeah.
No,
I'm,
I mean more like you were covering a thing independently.
Somebody entered your life and said,
you can't cover this.
Okay.
Kind of,
because it was an aspect of the story that I got from the
inside that they didn't want that aspect out as part of the
story that I was covering.
And I made them the promise that I wouldn't.
Well,
was that for the program?
No.
Okay.
It was earlier than that.
Earlier than that?
Well,
earlier and later.
Okay.
I'm not trying to be.
No,
no,
no.
It's okay.
They just asked me not to mention it.
Okay.
And I respect that.
How did they find out?
How did they find out that you were covering the thing?
Oh,
oh,
my,
my work is public.
Okay.
So you were like,
you were starting to surface.
It was a followup on a previous thing that I'd reported on.
And they were like,
don't take that further.
Don't,
don't, don't mention that.
I showed you this and don't mention that we.
Okay.
You know.
So I said,
I wouldn't.
Damn.
I know.
Do you want,
do you think that that,
if people knew that thing,
that would move the needle as far as overall disclosure?
No,
no,
not really.
Okay.
I,
I think the,
I think the Holman landing footage exists.
And I've talked to a number of people and I didn't,
when I,
when I first heard about it,
I was like,
come on,
no landing contact,
please.
Yeah.
Like,
come on.
Yeah.
You know?
Uh,
but now I'm convinced the Holman did happen.
And I think that would obviously move the needle,
particularly if,
you know.
Why are you convinced?
Well,
because I was investigating Socorro and that happened in 64,
April 24th,
1964.
And in the process I spent five years investigating that case
on and off.
I met with Ray Stanford,
RIP,
uh,
who was the,
one of the lead investigators wrote the book,
Socorro saucer in a Pentagon pantry.
And in the process of investigating,
I was reading all the articles.
I went to the house.
I befriended his wife,
Mary daughter,
son,
Michael,
and I'm reading,
I'm going through all the newspaper clippings.
I'm going to the national archives.
And I mean,
I'm really doing a deep dive into that case.
Cause my God,
it's a very good case.
And I came upon a couple of articles coincidentally,
haphazardly,
you know,
written by a corral Lorenzen of the UA UFO bulletin.
I think it was called.
And,
um,
she had talked about,
uh,
this land in Holman.
She interviewed someone that was in an airplane that witnessed it.
And someone that was on the ground at the base that witnessed it,
both military officials.
And apparently she was a respected journalist.
And,
and I was like,
Hmm,
this is interesting.
Like this is an original,
you know,
article.
And I was looking at it like,
Hmm.
And that led me to,
uh,
Bob,
come on.
Uh,
the two guys that made the film,
uh,
UFOs past,
present,
and Alan Sandler and Emanager in particular.
And then of course that led me to,
to Colonel William Coleman,
who had that dramatic encounter,
uh,
with the UFO and B-55 over Alabama.
But also he was later on part of project blue book.
He was public spokesman for the,
for the Pentagon during the time the film was being made.
And I started poking around and started as a side investigation.
I started to look into the landing case that they kind of,
um,
put forth as a concept that may something that might've happened already there.
Maybe it would happen in the future.
In their film,
right?
And,
uh,
and then that led me to,
to do Emanager who talked with the guy,
Paul Shardle,
who's at the archive process,
the film of the landing talked about it in great detail.
I interviewed Bob Emanager,
which I'm going to release for free.
All my archives coming up soon.
It's been so busy.
That's amazing.
I digitize them all.
And now they're all digitized.
Now I set to go through them and edit them.
And I'm going to,
and I'm going to put them all out there for free for everybody.
Cool.
Um,
but anyway,
and,
and based on that,
and then Alan Sandler was shown the footage by Paul Shardle.
He's convinced that it was a real flying saucer.
No question about it.
Three came in over the base,
two peeled away.
One came down and landed and he goes,
James,
just like in a,
in a sci-fi movie,
there was no,
there was like a seamless door that just opened and dropped.
Alan Sandler happens to think that it was our technology in this,
whenever it was shown to him in the seventies,
I think he was shown it in 72,
73,
but it was taken in the sixties.
I believe is what Paul Shardle said.
And he thinks it was our technology,
our flying saucers that we had,
and they dressed people up to look like aliens as a staged event.
But he goes,
it wasn't doctored.
It was a real flying saucer that really flew.
And that really came down and landed over the base.
And it was filmed on a tripod,
which means they anticipated it coming because you don't have a tripod camera
sitting on a tripod unless they're filming something else unrelated.
And then the event happened either that,
or they just saw it happening because I asked those details.
And he said they were met with a bunch of,
uh,
military base commanders in uniform,
got into a Jeep off.
They went discs,
just sat there on the ground.
And then the film footage ends.
He thinks it was staged.
He thinks it was a real disc,
real technology,
real flying saucer that really flew in the sixties.
And then it was,
uh,
that's what he thinks.
Why is it?
Why does he think that?
I don't know.
I guess it was hard for him to imagine that real aliens.
I don't,
I really don't know.
Okay.
But he said that they had,
uh,
yes,
headdresses,
big noses,
slits from mouth tall.
Yeah.
Kind of tall,
not,
not short.
So what was that?
Some sort of device that they assumed would have been a communication device.
Okay.
But if he's saying that,
is that like,
were there makeup artists involved?
Like why?
Evidently there would have been,
according to him,
it was like bullshit.
That was a real event.
It was an extraterrestrial Paul shuttle who had the footage,
who processed the footage and ordinary air force base.
Absolutely to his death said,
that was a real,
event.
And then of course,
I've talking to other people that have subsequently since then,
particularly he's come out with it.
Eric Davis said that,
uh,
either he was told about it.
President Bush was either senior was either told about it or shown it.
I can't remember.
Do you know,
I don't know,
said that he talked to president Bush about it.
I know there's some relation there,
but I don't know.
As head of the CIA,
he was made aware of it accidentally and that's how he became aware of it.
But I don't know if he was shown it.
Eric Davis would know.
So fascinating.
Well,
we could go back.
And forth all day,
man.
I love talking to you and you're such a treasure trove of deep knowledge when it
comes to UFOs and inspiration.
I don't really feel like that.
I know what I know,
talking directly to witnesses around the world and that's it.
But you have a much deeper understanding of so many of the complexities and
intricacies from what you do.
And I respect it,
but it's great.
We compliment each other.
I don't know.
I don't know anything,
man.
I know less than I did when I it's the more,
you know,
the less,
and the more,
the more questions,
you have and the weirder it gets,
you expect it to neatly collapse into,
oh,
it's like either all manmade,
you know,
anti-gravity vehicles plus plus MK ultra or whatever.
And then you go,
or it's just these beings and they're like from this specific place.
And you like,
no. And it's like,
I haven't gotten either of those.
Like it just keeps getting weirder and weirder as I'm sure you've experienced.
And so please,
you know,
don't put me in that position under the night sky in the remote desert and look
up.
And just realize just how vast the known universe is and the possibilities of
life.
One of the things that we covered and out of the blue,
very early on was like the equations of the possibilities of life in the
universe.
And it's like a hundred percent,
like it just comes out at a hundred.
There was a,
that book written by Amir Excel,
probability one years ago,
back in the nineties,
you know,
and it was like mathematically we are not alone.
Look,
you know,
come on.
Yes.
Could be all of you.
And life is bizarre.
Life is absurd and bizarre.
Consciousness itself is weird.
Yeah.
What I,
what is happening?
Nobody can,
you know,
has a great answer for that.
And,
uh,
I think the framing of disclosure,
it's both exciting because maybe we're on the precipice of this,
you know,
big reveal,
but it's also kind of a misnomer because I think,
you know,
per the messages that maybe a lot of these beings seem to transmit,
we're in more of a position ourselves to know the truth.
Then.
We might realize,
and I don't think the government has monopoly on an understanding of
metaphysics.
I do think they have asymmetric understanding of maybe some technology and
they may,
might have some more materials and might have some more footage and concrete
evidence than civilians do.
But the idea that they have some sort of like ontological understanding of
the universe that like,
you know,
people can't achieve without them giving that info.
I mean,
great.
Let's let's get the info amazing.
But it's also like a,
a low agency thing.
You know,
it's like we can,
we can do it ourselves too.
And,
and,
and anyone can understand this stuff if they reach for it.
So I don't know,
or,
or understand it or,
uh,
understand more of it.
You know,
the one that you pull on one thread,
you get like three more in its place,
but you know,
I think we can ascend much greater to much greater heights kind of intellectually
than,
you know,
we give ourselves credit for one little thing.
It was,
you said it wasn't,
I'm kidding.
Yeah.
You've got some guns.
You've got some gummy bears,
some James Fox gummy bears.
I just got this little,
just you know.
Yeah.
That's what it goes.
Speaking of which my swag.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
I want to thank you for having me on.
I want to thank you for all your support.
I really appreciate it.
Oh man.
I really,
I really mean that.
No,
it's an honor to get to know you and,
and,
um,
yeah,
really,
uh,
it's the,
it's moment of contact too.
New,
new revelations of alien encounters.
It was good.
We did a complete,
cause we,
we really felt like,
I felt like,
you know,
processing,
you got all the congressional hearings,
right?
And that like,
I,
I think about mainstream,
I think about skeptics,
fair enough.
It's very healthy to be skeptical,
but I think about trying to process like those allegations made under oath by Grosh and Lou
and all,
all the others,
um,
of crash retrievals and live aliens.
And,
you know,
biologics,
right?
So I kind of like took the first 20 minutes,
completely new,
condensed those congrats,
those hearings,
as you saw,
condense those hearings.
And then,
Hey,
you know what?
It's extraordinary.
As it sounds,
it's not the first time.
And I give really quick examples of various,
you know,
magenta,
we go to Italy,
we,
you know,
Roswell very quickly.
I don't get bogged down in those old cases,
but boom,
boom,
you know,
Kecksburg,
uh,
it's really good statements of craft landing up,
landing or crashed on the ground.
And then,
but the best case,
you know,
and then we do a deep dive into Virginia with all the new testimony from two forensic pathologists,
from the chief of police,
new crash witness,
plus the lead neurosurgeon at regional hospital.
And none of these people are coming forward in this new cut.
No one is coming forward anonymously.
They're putting their names,
their reputations,
their faces out there for the whole world to see.
Yeah.
Well,
thank God you did.
And thank God you went out there and got the footage and keep going back there.
And yeah,
it's just,
uh,
it's an honor to,
to speak with you.
Go watch this movie.
Cause I think it's going to be,
I think it's gonna be earth shattering,
especially watching Italo Venturelli,
this neurosurgeon,
just his revelation just feels so important.
This,
this,
this testimony of being face to face with an alien being for that long.
I'm told it's the first time in history.
Like,
you know,
we didn't have a video of Oswald,
right?
We didn't have the agenda on any of these other cases where we have,
we don't have video of,
you know,
yes.
Yeah.
I mean,
obviously it would be great to get the ultimate prize,
right?
I mean,
no,
but you have video of him and he,
and he's still alive now.
He's still alive.
He's like,
I asked him,
would you put your hand on a Bible?
Would you testify?
You know,
would you take a lot?
Yes.
All the above.
And now the whole entire doctor medical community in the region are all supporting him,
getting behind him.
There are other doctors that are considering when the time is right to come forward.
So we're at the beginning of the beginning.
I'm,
I'm quite honestly,
very excited about it and we'll see how it's received.
Yeah.
Well,
let's help your dream becomes a reality.
If somebody slips a thumb drive,
that's real in your pocket,
or maybe it goes down in a,
in a,
in a way that's more manageable for you.
I don't know,
but I'm trying,
even if it gets out there.
And by the way,
I'm going to make this abundantly clear.
Unless I have,
I have to,
if somebody gives me the footage,
I'm giving it away for free.
I'm not going to charge a dime for it.
I love that.
If I have to pay for it,
I'll have to recoup my investment to pay those people back.
And then I'll put it out there for free.
But if I get it,
I'll give it to the world for free.
I swear on my,
unless I have to pay for it,
reimburse the investors.
Yeah.
Then I'll reimburse it and then I'll put it out there for free.
Go to jamesfox.com.
It's behind a paywall.
No,
that won't happen.
I promise.
No,
I think that's the right attitude along with like,
you know,
wanting other people to follow up on your research.
Yes.
And you're,
you're the paradigmatic example of that because you're having Amar,
who's a good friend of mine and kind of.
Such a cool guy.
Yeah,
the best.
And he's kind of a correspondent for the show,
but he's kind of,
I think he's going to start his own thing.
Yeah.
I hope.
And he's going to go get some amazing footage with you.
Yes.
And so you've been so welcoming to me and him as far as,
you know,
come with me and.
Oh yeah.
That's not normal in the space of this.
There's,
there are a lot of people,
you know,
people who are like,
they're like,
you know,
they're like the quote unquote scoop.
Yeah.
And like,
I'll even see like,
I'll cover a thing.
And then somebody will try to like front run the thing.
It's like,
and I'm always like,
great,
good.
You cover it too.
We'll both cover it.
That's like,
whatever.
Yeah.
It's like,
we,
you know,
so I appreciate you.
And this was,
this was amazing,
man.
And I'm excited to,
to do this and hopefully do this many more times.
Thank you brother.
I appreciate it.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
And I'm excited to say that the 2025 winter drop is finally ready.
We now have 30 uniquely designed pieces that really reflect what American Alchemy is all
about.
This drop includes Epic T-shirts,
long sleeves,
crewnecks,
hoodies,
tapered sweatpants,
hats,
totes,
mugs,
and tumblers.
The Fukushima,
Japan pieces,
for example,
have detailed left chest embroidery.
The morning of earth designs went through multiple revisions to get the fit exactly
right.
And the iron horse tee is something I think will be,
will be,
be a hit for anyone who loved the UFO Cowboy or our Atomic Age shirts from our last drop.
We cut a lot of things that didn't meet our standards, and we're really, really proud
of each of these items.
Everything is pretty limited, so there's no endless restocks.
Once it's gone, it's entirely gone.
If you missed anything from our original drops and you want to go out and represent, now's
the time to go grab something.
So go to AmericanAlchemyMerch.com to check it all out.